PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AS WELL AS THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON NINE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND I
WELCOME THE CHAIR OF THAT
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
HERE AT BY SIDE. I OUT WHEN A
ESPECIALLY THANK OUR PANELISTS
WHO HAVE TRAVELLED HERE
ALTHOUGH ONE MISSED A PLANE
WHICH ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
IN A SECOND BUT FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE TRAVELLED HERE TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
DISCUSSIONS. WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR INCITING AND
YOUR INVOLVEMENT. IN THIS ISSUE.
TOGETHER OUR TWO COMMITTEES
CONDUCTOVERSIGHT OF REGULATORY
BOARDS AND PRACTICES ACT.
THROUGH THE SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT PROCESS. THE BOARD OF
BARBERENA IN COSMETOLOGY IS
SCHEDULED TO EXPIRE IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. GIVEN THE
CONSIDERABLE RESEARCH AND
COMMENTARY FROM ACROSS THE
ECONOMIC AND POLITICAL SPECTRUM
SUGGESTING THAT ARE
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING SYSTEM
MAY CREATE BARRIERS TO ENTRY
THAT ARE NOT NECESSARY TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. WE ARE FOCUSING ON THIS
TOPIC TO THE LANDS OF THE BOARD
OF BARBER IN COSMETOLOGY AND
THE PRACTICES THE BOARD
REGULATES. THIS IS OUR SECOND
HEARING IN A SERIES OF HEARINGS
ON THIS BOARD AND PRACTICES
SHE'S WITHIN THE BEAUTIFICATION
SERVICE INDUSTRY. IT MAY NOT BE
THAT WELL KNOWN BUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE LICENSE.
TO PRACTICE THAT THIS WORK
HERE. THAT'S QUITE A LOT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. I AS WE
LEARNED THAT ARE HEARING IN
AUGUST THE TRAINING REQUIRED
FOR LICENSURE. BY THE BOARD CAN
COST TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. AND INDIVIDUALS ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE. UP TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS OF TRAINING. MORE
THAN WHAT WE REQUIRE FOR POLICE
OFFICERS. EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS AND EVEN TATTOO
ARTISTS. OUR GOAL TODAY IS TO
LEARN ABOUT REQUIREMENTS FOR
LICENSURE OF PROFESSIONS
GENERALLY. AS WELL AS SPECIFIC
TRENDS THROUGHOUT THE NATION
AND THE REGULATION OF THE
BEAUTIFICATION SERVICES. BEFORE
WE WELCOME OUR FIRST WITNESS
I'D LIKE TO INVITE. ASSEMBLY%
MEMBER LOW CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE
ANY OPENING REMARKS THAT HE
WOULD LIKE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GLACIER AND THE UC OF THOSE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE A SECOND
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THAT
WE'VE ARE HOSTING AND GIVES THE
SENSE OF THE LEVEL SERIOUSNESS
THAT WE TAKE A TO THIS MEASURE
A PARTICULARLY WHEN WE ARE OUT
OF SESSION BUT SIMILARLY IN THE
REPORT WITH RESPECT TO. THE
COMMENTS THAT THE CHURCH LATER
MADE ON THE LIVER HOOVER
COMMISSION ON THE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE TO
CONTINUALLY TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE REGULATION
WILL ALSO INTERNED CONSUMER
PROTECTION BUT ALSO REMOVING AS
MANY BEERS TO ENTRY FOR THE
CURRENT EXISTENCE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO I LOOK FOR TO
THE CONTINUE DIALOGUE AND LET'S
GET GOING. GREAT THANK YOU SURE
LO AND THERE IS A BRIEF
DOCUMENT THAT'S BEEN PREPARED
FOR OUR WORK IN THIS AREA THOSE
HERE THE AUDIENCE CAN GET A
COPY OF THAT THAT THOSE ONLINE
ALSO AVAILABLE. OKAY SO IF
YOU'D LIKE A COPY OF IT AS A
TERRIFIC REVIEW ON THE
BACKGROUND ON THIS ISSUE AND A
VARIETY. OF PAPERS THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE. ON THIS ISSUE. OKAY
SO WITH THAT WITH OUR FIRST
SPEAKER IS MATCH A FOR I WAS A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST FOR THE
CENTER OF INNOVATION AT THE
COUNCIL STATE GOVERNMENT. AND
MATT I UNDERSTAND IT THAT YOU
HAD A LITTLE PLAIN CONNECTION
ISSUE. THAT IS NOT ABLE TO BE
HERE IN PERSON. BUT WE DO HAVE
A VIDEO LINK. LOOKING GOOD THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND WE ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER LINK UP YOUR SLIDES
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THE COURSE OF YOUR TESTIMONY.
SO WE'RE SORRY YOU'RE NOT HERE
IN PERSON BUT WE WELCOME YOU TO
OUR HEARING AND YOU MAY BEGIN.
AGAIN SINCE SINCERELY APOLOGIZE
THAT I AM I AM NOT. JUNE BUT
DELTA WAS A NICE TO ME
YESTERDAY YOU. CHEMICAL ISSUES
THEN WE COULD MAKE IT WORK BUT
I'M I'M EXCITED TO STILL HAVE
THE. SO WHAT I'M GOING TO DO
TODAY IS JUST TALK ABOUT US
FIVE. NATIONAL REGULATION OF
YOU ALL FIRST BRIEFLY TALK A
LITTLE. THE COUNCIL OF STATE
GOVERNMENTS SOMEWHERE AND
NONPARTISAN NONPROFIT WE'RE
GAME. GOVERNMENT SO YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD OF THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE
LEGISLATURES THE NATIONAL
GOVERNORS. CHEN IN THAT I WEAR
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION THAT
SERVES ITS STATE GOVERNMENT
WITH POLICY. WE ACTUALLY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH NCSL IN NGA
WILL. FULLER DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR GRANT TO SPECIFICALLY
HELP STATES LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
OF OUR. THIS THIS DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR GRANT THIS THREE PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE. IN THAT CAN
YOU HOLD ON JUST A SECOND. YES
JUST HOLLERS THAT WE'RE HAVING
TECHNICAL ISSUES HERE ON OUR
AND I LIKE TO ASK THE STAFF TO
SEE WHETHER WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
OTHER WITNESSES WE CAN GO TO
ONE OPTION WOULD BE TO JUST GET
A DIRECT AUDIO CONNECTION AND
THAT THE VIDEO LIKE IS THE ONE
THAT'S CREATING THE PROBLEM
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. SELF
SIGNAL. ALRIGHT BUT IF HE WAS
ON A LAND LINE. YEAH I THINK
HERE IN EVERYOTHER WORD FROM
YOU SO MAYBE OUR TECHNICAL
PEOPLE CAN TALK TO DIRECTLY AND
SEE WHETHER WE CAN JUST DO AN
AUDIO LINK THROUGH A LAN LINE.
THAT WOULD TAKE AWAY THIS VIDEO
CHALLENGE THAT WERE STILL
EXPERIENCING AND WE CAN HEAR
FROM OUR OTHER WITNESSES IS
THAT. I YEAH THAT THAT WORKS
THAT WORKS OKAY I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU ACCESS TO A LAND LINE BUT
I'M IT PRESUMES THAT WE CAN
CONTACT YOU DIRECTLY NOW WHILE
WE HEAR THE OTHER WITNESSES AND
YOU CAN. SEE WE CAN FIGURE THAT
OUT. AND YOUR FROZEN AGAIN OKAY.
STAFF ANYBODY ELSE ONE EIGHT
PROVIDING INPUT OR THAT'LL BE
THE DIRECTION WILL WILL HAD.
SERGEANT FOR GETTING THE
BACKBONE ON YOUR WAY. ONCE WE
GET IT I DON'T KNOW. THEM
TOGETHER. YEAH YOU WANNA GO GO
TO THE NEXT WITNESS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THAT THAT THAT'LL BE WILL
TRY TO DO OKAY SO THAT IF YOU
CAN STAND BY OUR OUR- TECHNICAL
STAFF WILL GIVE YOU A CALL AND
SEE IF WE CAN CORRECT CREATE
JUSTIN AUDIO LINK. YOU KNOW
YOUR SLIDES AND WE CAN TRY TO
FOLLOW ALONG HERE BUT WE JUST
ONCE YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
FROM KENTUCKY IS THAT WHERE YOU
ARE. YES SIR IT IS OKAY GOOD SO
STAND BY WE DO HAVE LIKE TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES I'D LIKE
TO INVITE TO COME UP TO KICK US
OFF THEY ARE. LESLIE RUSTY AT
THE NATIONAL DIRECTOR FOR
EDUCATION MARKET DEVELOPMENT A
KING RESEARCH. AND ADAM
HIGGINBOTHAM. WHO IS THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
NEVADA STATE BOARD OF
COSMETOLOGY. WESLEYAN ADAM CAN
YOU COME ON UP. HERE AND GRAB A
SEAT IN FRONT OF US THAT BE
GREAT THE ME JUST MENTIONED
WHILE THEY'RE GETTING. SEATED
THAT WE DO PROVIDE ALL OF OUR
PUBLIC HEARINGS THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY WILL BE PROVIDING
THAT AT THE AT THE AT THE END
OF OUR HEARING HERE THIS
MORNING SO. REMEMBER THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE WE
WILL WELCOME YOU ANNA AND A
LITTLE WHILE SO WITH THAT
LESLIE AND ADAM THANK YOU BOTH
FOR BEING HERE. WHO WAS GOING
FIRST THERE AS FISH LESLIE.
YEAH SO SEE IF YOU'RE A. NUMBER
PRESS PRESS AGAIN. AT A LATER
ON THERE YOU GO. I CAN'T ABOUT
YOU MOVE A LITTLE CLOSER TO YOU
IF YOU CAN. I'M NOT TALL ENOUGH
TO MAKE IT WORK VERY WELL.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME A
LITTLE BIT YOU MAY HAVE MISSED
BIOGRAPHY ON ME AND THE-
MATERIALS THAT YOU HAVE.
BASICALLY MY ROLE IN THIS WOULD
BE THAT I HAVE SPENT THE BETTER
PART OF THE LAST ELEVEN YEARS
TRAVELING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
WORKING WITH. VIRTUALLY EVERY
STATE. ON HOW TO FIGURE OUT
THIS SORT OF CONUNDRUM WE'VE
GOTTEN GOTTEN INTO WITH
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING. IN THE
COSMETOLOGY AND BARBERENA
ARENA. I'M A BIG PORTION OF IT
IS THAT MY BACKGROUND IS NOT IN
COSMETOLOGY MY BACKGROUND IS IN
OR SEEN AND MICROBIOLOGY SO. MY
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN AT REFOCUSING
US ON WHERE LICENSURE WAS MEANT
TO BE WHICH IS AND HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. SO I'VE HELP
STATES ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
WITH REVISING THE RULES. THEIR
CURRICULUM AND NOW A LOT OF
STATES LOOKING AT REVISING WHAT
THEY'RE REQUIRING AS ENTRY
POINTS. THE CRITERIA FOR ENTRY
INTO THIS CAREER FIELD. PUT
TOGETHER A LITTLE BIT OF THE
HISTORY OF WHAT'S GOING ON ON
THEIR OUT THERE RIGHT NOW ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. SOME OF THE
TRENDS THAT WE'RE SEEING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IS PRESSURE
LITERALLY IN EVERY STATE. TO
REDUCE OCCUPATIONAL LICENSURE.
SCENE THE MOST COMMON THING I
HEAR IS GOVERNOR'S WHO ARE
GIVING A 30% REDUCTION. THEY
WANT 30% ACROSS THE BOARD
PAPERWORK. OCCUPATIONAL HAZARD
WHATEVER YOU CAN DO TO REDUCEBY 30% SEEMS TO BE A NUMBER
THAT IS PRETTY PREVAILING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. SO LOTS OF
STATES ARE MAKING AN EFFORT TO
REDUCE BOTH THE RULES ON THEIR
CURRICULUM AND ALL THEIR
LICENSURE BY ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT. THE CHANGING JOB
MARKET I HAVE UP THERE WHICH IS
KIND OF INTERESTING. IN AND OUT
OF CAN PROBABLY SPEAK TO THIS
LITTLE BIT BETTER BUT- THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR IS
ESTIMATING THAT IN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS. WE'LL SEE SOMEWHERE
AROUND FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
WITHOUT A JOB BASED ON.
AUTOMATION ROBOTICS AND-
ARTIFICIAL OR- ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. AND THOSE PEOPLE
OUT BE OUT LOOKING FOR JOBS AND
WHEN YOU'RE THIRTY SEVEN WITH A
MORTGAGE AND THREE KIDS IT'S
KIND OF DIFFICULT TO GO AND
SPEND ANOTHER FOUR YEARS GOING
TO GET A UNIVERSITY DEGREE. SO
THERE ARE SOME PRESSURES IN
THAT REGARD A TOWARDS WHAT WE
WOULD HAVE CALLED LOCATIONS IN%
THE PAST TO TRY TO GET THE
BEARS ENTRY LOWERED. SO THAT
MORE PEOPLE HAVE CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES AND THOSE FIELDS.
ON AND THEN MOST STATES THAT
COMING OUT TRULY FUNDING HONEST
THEY WANT TO HAVE A PREEMPTIVE
TO THE DEREGULATION. RISK THEY
WANT TO DO WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO
SO PEOPLE DON'T COME IN AND
TRYING TO DEREGULATE THEM
ENTIRELY. SO IF I'M BEING
TOTALLY HONEST THAT'S WHY A LOT
OF STATES COME OUT TO TRY TO
HELP THEM SO THAT THEY DON'T
IT'S A PREEMPTIVE STRIKE.
BEFORE SOMEBODY COMES IN AND
GET THE BILL SUCCESSFUL
SUCCESSFULLY. TO DE REGULATE
THEM. SOME OF THE THINGS I'M
SAYING THE MOST COMMON THING IS
SEEN AS PRODUCTION HOURS. NEW
YORK AND MASSACHUSETTS. HAVE
ALWAYS HAD A THOUSAND HOURS AS
THEIR. TWO POINT AND SO TO
TESTING THOSE TO STATE THAT THE
THOUSAND HOURS TO BE CLEAR
MASSACHUSETTS. IS THE NUMBER
ONE MOST ON OUR STATE ON TO FOR
JUSTICE LIST AND THAT IS
BECAUSE- IT'S A THOUSAND HOURS
AND IN THE CLASSROOM BUT THEY
ALSO REQUIRE. TWO HOURS OF
APPRENTICESHIP OR TWO YEARS OF
APPRENTICESHIP ON TOP OF THAT
SO. IT DOES BECOME MUCH MORE
LIKE THE PROCESS BUT I'M GONNA
SHOW YOU WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO
CHANGE THAT MASSACHUSETTS.
WHICH IS KIND OF INTERESTING.
TEXAS VERMONT INTO A THOUSAND
HOURS THIS YEAR ON TEXAS
DOESN'T TAKE PLACE UNTIL.
NUMBER TWENTY. BUT THAT'S BEEN
INTERESTING TO WATCH THAT
CHANGE OVER ONE OF THE
INTERESTING THINGS ABOUT TEXAS
IS THEY'VE BEEN DOING A
THOUSAND HOURS AND THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL PROGRAM. FOR EVER AND SO
IF YOU WERE TO DECIDE AT
SIXTEEN I WANT TO BE A
COSMETOLOGIST YOU COULD GO FOR
THOUSAND HOURS. GET YOUR
CERTIFICATE AND GRADUATE AND
BECOME A COSMETOLOGIST. IF THE
DAY AFTER YOU GRADUATED HIGH
SCHOOL YOU WANT TO BECOME A
COSMETOLOGIST TO KEEP FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS SO. THAT WAS SORT
OF THERE WAS A- SORT AN EASY
TRANSITION FOR THEM. FLORIDA IS
GOING TO TWELVE HUNDRED HOURS
ELEVEN STATES TO REDUCE THEIR
HOURS IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
THAT REDUCTION MIGHT NOT BE
SIGNIFICANT SOME STATES HAVE
GONE TO TWENTY FROMTWENTY ONE
HUNDRED HOURS. TO EIGHT HAN
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED HOURS BUT
THEY'RE STILL STARTING TO
REDUCE AND THEN WE HAVE EIGHT
STATES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
LOOKING TO REDUCE THEIR HOURS.
MOST OF THEM WERE TRYING TO GET
TO A THOUSAND. THAT IS SEEMS TO
BE THE GOAL THAT EVERYONE'S
TRYING TO GET TO. NOW. SOME OF
THE OTHER METHODS OF LICENSURE
THAT ARE GOING ON OUT THERE
THAT WERE SEEN. IN
MASSACHUSETTS. NEW AND
INNOVATIVE. THEY'RE HAVING A
FEW ISSUES WITH IT AND I'M
GOING TO BRING UP WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE WHEN THEY DO ON.
THEY HAVE A PROGRAM NOW WHERE
THEY SPEND SIX HUNDRED HOURS IN
THE SCHOOL AND FOUR HUNDRED
HOURS. ARE IN A PAID AND I ONLY
PAID BECAUSE THAT'S SIGNIFICANT
FOR THEM. A PAID
APPRENTICESHIPS SO THAT
STUDENTS AND GO OUT AND WORK.
NOT IN A SORT NOT IN A SCHOOL
SETTING BUT OUT IN A SALON
SETTING WHETHER. A PRACTICE BY
THE- ASSEMBLY SALON OWNERS. THE
REQUIRED TO BE PAID DURING
THAT. TIME PERIOD. SO THEY'RE
STARTING TO. YOU KNOW ON WHILE
THEY LEARN TYPE OF CNCEPT. THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM THEY'RE HAVING
WITH IT IS THEY WOULD SAY THE
CAUTIONARY NOTE THERE IS TO
HAVE GOOD OVERSIGHT EVERY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. I
HEARD PRESENTATION BY AN FBI
AGENT COUPLE YEARS AGO ABOUT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND-
APPRENTICESHIP SEEM TO BE A WAY
A LOT OF. HIM TRAFFICKING CASES
ARE FUNNELED INTO THE STATE'S.
SO REAL CAUTION WITH THE
OVERSIGHT ON THAT WAS WHAT THEY
WOULD TELL YOU. OREGON HAS BEEN
DOING COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION INTESTINE THEY'VE
OFFERED IT FOR A NUMBER OF.
YEARS WHAT THEY HAVE. EVERYBODY
I TALKED TO THE WORKING PEOPLE
OF WORK WITH IN OREGON. THE
GREAT THING ABOUT IT IS
STUDENTS PROCEED AT THEIR OWN
PACE BASED ON WHAT THE COMPANY
SAYS SO ARGUABLY YOU COULD
FINISH SCHOOL. MUCH SOONER IF
YOU CAN DEMONSTRATE COMPETENCE
MORE READILY. YOU COULD ALSO DO
COMPETENCY BASED TESTING THAT
WOULD ALLOW STUDENT THAT IS
VERY. IS ABLE TO FINISH IN A
VERY MUCH SHORTER TIME THAN
SOMEBODY WHO REQUIRES A LITTLE
BIT MORE. THEIR BIGGEST
CHALLENGE IN THE REASON ONLY
ABOUT TWENTY SCHOOLS ARE 20% OF
THE SCHOOLS OFFER. COMPETENCY
BASED EDUCATION AN ORGAN IS
BECAUSE OF FINANCIAL AID SO
IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET FINANCIAL
AID FOR THE STUDENTS AND SO. ON
THEY HAVE A DROP OFF OF
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO DO THAT I
KEEP LOOKING YOU TO CHANGE JUST.
THIS SEEMS TO BE THE MOST
POPULAR THING EVERYBODY'S
LOOKING AT AND ORGAN HAS BEEN
DOING THIS ACTUALLY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. YOU WOULD
KIND OF NOT BY THE WAY THAT
THEIR STRUCTURE REALLY WORKS.
BUT STACKABLE LICENSES IS
REALLY WHAT I HEAR OTHER STATE
WANTING TO TALK ABOUT DOING. AN
IN OREGON THEY TOOK AWAY THE
COSMETOLOGY UMBRELLA LICENSE
ENTIRELY THEY THERE YOU CAN'T
GET IT BACK BECAUSE LICENSE IN
OREGON ANYMORE. YOU KNOW GET A
HAIR DESIGN LICENSE WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES CHEMICALS AYE
BARBERING LICENSE AND AESTHETIC
LICENSE OR NAILS LICENSE YOU GO
IN AND YOU DO THE ONE THING.
THE ONE AREA THAT YOU WANT TO
WORK IN. AND THEN YOU CAN GO
BACK AND GET ANOTHER LICENSE
AND YOU CAN CONTINUE TO GET ALL
FOUR OF THE LICENSES. BUT YOU
DON'T TO YOU DO YOU DO NOT. GET
ONE COSMETOLOGY LICENSE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT REDUCES A
BARRIER TO ENTRY BECAUSE NOW I
CAN GO AND GET A NAILS LYSONS
IN TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE HOURS
AND SEVENTY OPERATIONS. ON A
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY SIGNIFICANT
LAST TIME AND SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS MONEY. IF ALL I EVER WANT
TO DO IS NAILS. THEY'VE TAKEN
HELP THE PUBLIC SAFETY OUT OF A
GENERIC CLICK FOR EXAMPLE
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE A HELP THE
PUBLIC SECTOR AN INFECTION
CONTROL. ON NUMBER OF HOURS
THAT EVERYBODY HAS TO DO. IN
ORGAN WHAT THEY'VE DONE IS EACH
OF THOSE SEPARATE LICENSES HAS
ITS OWN HEALTH AND PUBLIC
SAFETY OR INFECTION CONTROL
COMPONENT. AND IT IS BASED
SPECIFICALLY. ON THAT THE
PRACTICE. ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY WOULD TELL YOU AS A
CAUTIONARY TALE THE STATE WOULD
TELL YOU THAT'S NOT THE SCHOOL.
BECAUSE OF I TALKED SCHOOL THAT
TIME IS FOR THE STATE IT. IS
THAT THERE'S A TENDENCY TO WANT
TO BUNDLE THESE AT THE- SCHOOL
LEVEL. SO THAT BECAUSE FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE NAILS AND THE
AESTHETICS BY THEMSELVES. WOULD
NOT QUALIFY. FINANCIAL BATES.
BUNDLE THEM. SO WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS BETTER THAN FIFTY
PERCENT. OF THE STUDENTS TODAY.
CAN ARE GOING THE FULL.
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED HOURS AND
BASICALLY. GETTING A COP
LICENSE BUT. DELTA THERE THERE.
THERE'S AN INSIDE THEM TO COULD
NOT TOGETHER SO. THERE ARE SOME
CAUTIONARY TALES AND HOW TO
MAKE THAT WORK A LITTLE BIT
BETTER. THIS IS SORT OF THE
OVERRIDING PROBLEM THAT I WOULD
SAY THAT WE HAVE IN HOW WE DO
LICENSING TODAY. IS THAT THIS
IS HOW MOST OF OUR CURRICULUM
SO TODAY. ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT IT NO MATTER WHAT MY CAR
80% OF MY HOURS SEEM TO BE IN
THE HAIR INDUSTRY. AND 20% SET
AND NAILS AND SKIN. BUT THIS IS
THE RISK THAT WE SEE OUT THERE
FROM HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF INJURIES THAT WE
SEE. COME OUT OF THE NAIL AND
THE SKIN MARKET. AND THE FEW
THAT COME OUT OF HER MARKET ARE
ALMOST ALWAYS CHEMICAL RELATED.
AND SO. THERE DOES NEED IN MY
ROOM IN MY ESTIMATION NEED TO
BE SOME DRIVE TOWARDS GETTING
TOWARD. ADDING TO REGULATE
STARTING TO WRITE CURRICULUM
STARTING TO MAKE THE ENTRY TO
THIS PROFESSION BE BASED ON HOW
DO I. MITIGATE THE RISK OF
WHERE THE RISK REALLY LIVE
LET'S REALLY TALK ABOUT THAT
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT WHERE THE
RISKS ARE. THERE ARE REAL RISK
IN THIS INDUSTRY BUT LET'S BE
HONEST WHAT THEY ARE AND LET'S
START THERE AND LET'S WORK FROM
THAT POINT. ON THE FEDERAL
CONVERSATION WHICH I THINK MATT
MATT WAS THAT HE WAS IS GOING
TO GET TO I'LL PREFACE IT A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE HE WAS
GETTING READY TO TALK ABOUT THE
AWESOME OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM. AND WHAT
THAT WAS WAS A JOINT EFFORT
BETWEEN NCSL IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR AND THEY TOOK I THINK
IT STARTED TEN STATES I THINK
IT AND NOT BEING EIGHTEEN
STATES. MADE SOME TEAMS AND WE
LOOKED AT THIRTY LICENSE
OCCUPATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND IT WAS REALLY A SURVEY PUT
A BEST PRACTICE DURING WHAT
COULD HAPPEN WHAT HAPPENED I
DON'T BRING IT UP. ONE NUMBER
OF MARYLAND HOME TEAM HAS THAT
I WAS SELECTED FOR THE HOME
TEAM BECAUSE WE LOOKED AT
COSMIC COSMETOLOGY BARBERING WE
ALSO LOOKED AT PLUMBING HVAC
AND REALTORS AND THE MARYLAND
TIME TEAM. THERE ARE TWO THINGS
THAT WERE TAKE AWAYS FOR ME
THAT I THOUGHT WERE SIGNIFICANT
ONE IS THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE A
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OUT AND
THE GENERAL PUBLIC. ABOUT HOW
HARD SOME OF THESE JOBS WILL BE
TO FILL IN THE COMING YEARS
SAID THAT NOBODY WANTS THEIR
KID TO NOT GO TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY THAT IS EVERY.
PARENT'S NIGHTMARE ACCORDING TO
THESE PEOPLE THAT THEIR CHILD
WILL NOT USE IT FOR YOUR
EDUCATION AT THEIR CHILD CHOOSE
A LOCATION SO THAT WE DO NEED
TO MAKE THESE OCCUPATIONS WE
NEED TO KEEP THEM I IN MY
OPINION STRUCTURED WE NEED TO
KEEP THEM AT A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE. A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN A STUDENT COMES HOME AND
SAYS I WANT TO BE A PLUMBER I
WANT TO BE A COSMETOLOGIST
WHATEVER THOSE THINGS ARE THE
TO DISAPPOINTMENT AND THIS IS
WHAT I HEARD FROM HIS MEDIAN IS
A DISAPPOINTMENT TO THEIR
PARENTS AND I THINK KEEP. IT A
LITTLE MORE ON THE. THING AND I
GET TO GO TO WORK SOONER I
DON'T HAVE TO SPEND ALL THIS
TIME. THEY WERE MORE SUCCESSFUL
AND THEY REPORTED MORE JOB
SATISFACTION IN THE LONG TERM.
BECAUSE THE OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE
AND WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN A TYPICALLY.
A WELL ESTABLISHED IN THEIR
LIVES THERE TYPICALLY IN THESE
CAREER PATHS IN THEIR EARLY
TWENTIES. THEY JUST WANT TO GET
TO WORK THEY WANT TO DO THIS
THING SO. WHAT WE CAN DO TO GET
THEM OUT FASTER AND LEARNING.
ON THEIR FEET. WHAT I'M A
NURSE. AND YOU WOULDN'T WANT ME
TO BE YOUR NURSE ON MY FIRST AT
A NURSING SCHOOL I WAS NOT
GREAT. I LEARNED THE VAST
MAJORITY OF I LEARNED ABOUT
BEING A NURSE BEING ON THE
FLOOR RIGHT I DIDN'T. I DIDN'T
LEARN IT ON SCHOOL I LEARNED A
LOT IN SCHOOL BIG PREPARED ME.
FOR WHAT I LEARNED ON THE FLOOR
SO. I UNDERSTAND THAT GET TO
WORK. ON AND WHAT. THERE IS A
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR REPORT
THAT'S GOING TO BE RELEASED. IT
MIGHT BE RELEASED THIS WEEK.
AND I WAS REVIEWER ON THAT
REPORT. AND WHAT THAT REPORT. I
CAN ONLY SENATE JORDAN GENERAL
SENSE IS GOING TO. SUPPORT AT
AM IS LICENSURE FOR THE HELP
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ASPECT. OF
WHAT. WHAT IS DONE IN THIS
FIELD. AND CERTIFICATION FOR
THE TECHNIQUE AREAS SO WHEN WE
START TALKING ABOUT HOW TO
SOMEBODY DO SOMETHING NOT DO
THEY DO IT SAFELY WHEN WE SAY
HOW DO YOU DO IT. THAT WOULD
BECOME MORE OF A CERTIFICATION
A TECHNIQUE. ISSUE VERSUS A
LICENSURE ISSUE. LIKE I HAVE TO
SAY THIS BECAUSE THERE ARE REAL
RISKS THERE ARE REAL RISKS IN
THE REAL RISK THESE ARE THE
MIDDLE OF THE ROAD I COULD SHOW
YOU REALLY NASTY PICTURES MAKE
YOU ALL GO GROW I MEAN I'VE-
HUNDREDS OF DISGUSTING PICTURES
ON MY COMPUTER. I USED TO WORK
ON THESE ON AIRPLANES AND TELL
PEOPLE SITTING NEXT TO ME GAVE
ME DIRTY LOOKS. BUT THESE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE NOT UNCOMMON
RIGHT A CHEMICAL BURN FROM
SOMEBODY GETTING A HAIR COLOR
SERVICE. A MIKE THIS IS
ACTUALLY INTERESTING BECAUSE
MICROPLATE THE EYEBROWS OR SEEN
DOWN HERE ON THE BOTTOM. MOST
PEOPLE CONSIDER THAT EVEN NOT
EVEN IN EVEN REGULATED FIELD
BECAUSE IT TAKES SO LONG FOR
STATES TO CATCH UP WITH WHAT.
GOES ON OUT IN THE REAL WORLD
THE BY THE TIME THE STATE RIGHT
TO RULE PEOPLE OF ALL SORTS ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS. THIS ACTIS.
AND CREATING ALL KINDS OF HAVOC
AND ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I
DO SEE STATES FACING IS THAT.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS I'M OF A
PROPONENT OF KEEPING SOME
LICENSE FROM PLACE. IS THAT.
WHAT I'M NOT A COME TELL JUST I
DON'T OFFEND ANY COSMETOLOGIST
SITTING BEHIND ME. BUT THE
REALITY IS THEY COME UP WITH
SOME REALLY DUMB IDEAS. THEY
THAT ARE PAID THAT HURT PEOPLE
RIGHT AND SO WE HAVE TO KEEP
OUR ARMS AROUND IT WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO SAY. NO YOU CAN'T DO
THAT IF YOU DO WHAT YOU HAVE TO
DO IT THIS WAY. IN ORDER TO BE
SAFE SO IS RUSTY WHAT WAS THE
PROCEDURE BEING DONE THE
EYEBROWS MICRO GERMAN LINE ON
THAT. MIKE MY KERN MICRO
PLANING ON EYEBROWS. MICRO
BLADING ITS THE BLADE THAT THEY
RUN THROUGH THE EYEBROWS AND
THEY- PUT. SOME KIND OF A
PIGMENT IN THERE AND IT MAKES
EYEBROWS AND THESE OTHER I GET
HUNDREDS OF THESE. LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF THESE PICTURES A
MONTH. PEOPLE SENDING ME THOSE
INJURIES. BUT IN MOST STATES
THEY CONSIDERED NON REGULATED
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SPECIFICALLY
REGULATED YET IT'S KIND OF A-
NEW. SORT OF A NEW TECHNIQUE SO
IS THAT A TATOO. IT IS A FORM
OF ATTACH IT'S NOT IT WOULDN'T
FALL UNDER THAT YOUR TATTOO
REGULATIONS. SO IT'S A FORM OF
TATTOOING THAT WOULD NOT
FOUNDER TATTOO REGULATIONS AND
I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON TATTOOING
BUT- ISN'T THERE A LOT OF
REDNESS AND SORENESS THAT
HAPPENS IT TO. SOME OF THESE
ARE VERY LONG TERM INJURIES SO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE LITTLE IN
THESE TACKLE END UP WITH A YEAR
JUST GIVE AN EXAMPLE CS ONE
UNDERSTAND OF THE ONE ON THE
TOP RIGHT I DO WANT TO BE THE
ONE OF THE TOP RATED YOU WANNA
SPEND A SECOND ON BECAUSE THIS
IS SOMETHING WE FORGET WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WHAT SOMEBODY GETS
EDUCATED ON A COSMETOLOGY
SCHOOL. AS A LADY HAD A
MASTECTOMY FOR BREAST CANCER.
AND GOVERNOR ELSTON AND
SOMEBODY USED A NOT PROPERLY
DISINFECTED EMPLOYMENT ON HER
AND SHE NOW HAS PERMANENT
DAMAGING TO HER LEFT ARM IS
MUCH LARGER THAT HER RIGHT ARM.
AND PATIENTS THAT HAD
MASTECTOMIES MONTH ACTIVITIES
ONE BATMAN CARE CAN MAKE THEM
PERMANENTLY HAVE. REALLY JUST
FIGURING OUT COMES AND SO SOME
OF THESE THINGS ARE JUST THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD BE TEACHING WE
SHOULD BE XIN OUT TO THE PUBLIC
WE. SHOULD BE TEACHING THE
CONSUMER BUT ALSO BE SPENDING
TIME ON IT. I MET THE WOMAN WHO
HAS LIVED A DAM AND HER ONE
RIGHT ARM WAY SIXTY POUNDS ONE
ARM WAY SIXTY POUNDS. SHE'S
DISABLED FROM WORKING SHE I
MEAN SHE HAS ALL KINDS OF
DISABILITY. AND HERS CAME FROM
A MANAGER SITUATION SO ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE REAL RISK
THERE I'M NOT GOING TO YOU KNOW
SHOW YOU THAT CRAZY THINGS ON.
YOU KNOW THERE'S LITTLE THINGS
THAT HAPPEN IS BIG THINGS
HAPPEN ON THE OTHER IN. RARE
CIRCUMSTANCES. I'VE TESTIFIED
WRONGFUL DEATH CASES BUT- I'VE
ASSOCIATED. WITH THOSE OF THE
RARITIES THESE OF THE COMMON
THINGS THAT YOU WOULD EXPECT
THE SAM. IF I CAN INTERRUPT
YOU AGAIN I'M ALWAYS WELL WAS
SOMEWHAT WARY ABOUT ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION EVEN PICTURES BUT-
CAN YOU SPEAK TO. ME SAY THIS
IS COMMON. I GOT A PRECAUTION
FLIGHT SAY WELL. YOU GOT TO
GIVE A CONTEXT IS THERE ANY
CONTEXT YOU CAN GIVE TO. THAT
THAT'LL GET YOUR RIGHT IN WHAT
I WHAT I WAS TRYING TO SAY IS
IT THESE ARE THEM SORT OF
MIDDLE OF THE ROAD THINGS IF
YOU WERE TO TALK TO THE
LICENSING. THE BOARD IN ANY
STATE. AND THEY WERE TO SAY WE
GOT FIVE HUNDRED COMPLAINTS OF
INJURY THIS YEAR. THE VAST
MAJORITY ARE GONNA FALL INTO
THINGS LIKE THIS A CHEMICAL
BURN OKAY. USUALLY THESE ARE
ILLUSTRATIONS OF THE THINGS
THAT CAN HAPPEN IS NOT A
REFLECTION ON. WHETHER IT'S 1%
OF THOSE WHO HAVE THOSE
PROCEDURES OR- 10% OR FRACTION
OF A PERSON THAT'S VERY ALSO
DIFFICULT TO TELL BECAUSE-
QUITE FRANKLY. A LOT OF FOR
EXAMPLE THE SCROLL DOWN ON THE
BOTTOM RIGHT. THIS IS AN
INFECTIOUS PROCESS SHE HAD HER
EYEBROWS WAXED IN TWENTY ELEVEN
THIS IS HOW SHE LOOKED IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. BUT IT TOOK
AWHILE FOR THE INFECTION TO
TAKE PLACE RIGHT SHE GOT THE
SHE WAS EXPOSED TO THE- TO A
BACTERIA. SHE GOT AN INFECTION
AND BY THE TIME SHE WENT TO THE
BOARD IN THE STATE SHE WAS AND
THEY SAID WELL YOU KIND OF GOT
MY SUMMER ELSE. THERE IS A
DISASSOCIATION IS NOT UNLIKE IF
I TRY TO COME HERE AND TELL YOU
THAT PEOPLE GET FOOD POISONING
RESTAURANTS AND YOU ASKED ME TO
GIVE ME YOUR NUMBER. I CAN'T I
CAN'T DEFINITIVELY SAY I GOT IT
FROM THIS RESTAURANT BECAUSE I
GOT SICK TWELVE HOURS LATER SO
I CAN GIVE YOU NUMBER BUT WHAT
I CAN SAY. IS THE NUMBER THAT
ARE REPORTED. OUR IS PROBABLY
UNDER REPORTED FOR THE NUMBER
OF INJURIES THAT ACTUALLY EXIST
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE A HARD TIME
AGAIN CORRELATION BETWEEN THE
TWO THINGS. THAT MAKE SENSE ONE
THING IT DOES FOR THE THAT
PEOPLE FALL OFF OF THANKS DOES
THAT MAKE BICYCLE RIDING ON
SAFE. AND THEN WE LOOK FOR
CONTEXT THERE RIGHT. AND IS WE
MAKE THEM DECIDE ABOUT LAWS
REGULATING HELMETS WE TRIED AT
LEAST HAVE SOME CONTEXT. I
THINK WHAT'S DIFFERENT I GET
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I THINK
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS IN
A LOT OF OTHER. LICENSED
OCCUPATIONS. IS THAT WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS IT'S OKAY FOR YOU TO
PUT YOUR HANDS ON OTHER OTHER
PEOPLE STRANGERS. AND USE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS CHEMICALS
MACHINES ALL KINDS OF THINGS ON
OTHER HUMAN. IF I RIDE A BIKE
AND I FALL OFF. IT'S ME AND MY
BIKE RIGHT IN AND I'VE I AM I
HAVE TO RIDE MY BIKE SAFELY
IT'S MY DECISION. BUT WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IN IN THE BEAUTY
INDUSTRY IS WERE ALLOWING
PEOPLE. SOMETIMES PEOPLE THAT
ARE MAYBE NOT EVEN VERY WELL
EDUCATED TO. THERE WERE USING
THINGS AT THE LABELS MIGHT NOT
ADEQUATELY REFRESH THE ****
WITH THAT PRODUCT CAN DO SO I
THINK THERE IS A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD THE
ARGUMENT FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT I
CAN GO BY HER COLOR TARGET. AND
THAT HAVE TO A LICENSE PLATE ON
WHAT THE COLOUR TARGET ALL I DO
IS MAKE TWO THINGS TOGETHER
THERE IS NO QUESTION HOW I DO
IT RIGHT HOW I MIX THOSE TWO
THINGS TOGETHER I DON'T HAVE
ANY DISCRETION ON WHETHER I USE
MORE OF A CHEMICAL OR NOT SO I
THINK IT IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. IF OKAY IN ALL
FAIRNESS OR NOT AND THEN LAST
BUT NOT LEAST I DO THIS IS
PROBABLY THE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
EVER WRITING THINGS PEOPLE
FORGET AND THAT IS. RECIPROCITY
IF I IF A PERSON IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A LICENSE AND LET'S SAY IN
ANY STATE LET'S SAY A STATE
GOES WAY LOW LET'S. TAKE A FIVE
HUNDRED HOURS. PART OF BEING
ABLE TO MOVE AND CONTINUE YOUR
EMPLOYMENT AND OTHER STATE IS
TO GET A LICENSE IN ANOTHER
STATE BECAUSE- EVEN IF
CALIFORNIA WERE TO MAKE A
CHANGE. FIRST OF FORTY NINE
OTHER STATES OUT THERE THAT
STILL HAVE A REQUIREMENT FOR
ENTRY INTO THEIR STATE TO
BECOME LICENSE. A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF THAT IS IN FLORIDA
THEY MOVED THEIR NAIL AND
AESTHETICS. TURNED ME INTO A
CERTIFICATION INSTEAD OF A
LICENSE. AND NOBODY WILL ACCEPT
AS THE ESTHETICIANS OR NOW TAX.
IN ANY OF THE OTHER STATES TO
COME WORK THERE BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT LICENSED. OR CERTIFIED. SO
THERE ARE THINGS TO CONSIDER
I'M NOT SAYING YOU CAN YOU
CAN'T DO ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
DO. BUT YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER
WHAT IT DOES TO YOUR CURRENTLY.
LICENSED PEOPLE AND ALL THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WANT TO GET
LICENSE OR WANT TO WORK AS A
COSMETOLOGIST. IF THEY WANT TO
LEAVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RIGHT THAT DOES BECOME OF. A
BIGGER ISSUE. I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT INCLUDES OUR MILITARY
FAMILIES. IMMIGRANTS ALREADY
HAVE ENOUGH PROBLEMS RIGHT
MOVING FROM ONE STATE TO
ANOTHER AND ALL OF THOSE GROUPS
OFPEOPLE WILL BE. WHAT
DIFFICULTY LEAVING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IF THEIR CAREER PATH
IS. AS A COSMETOLOGIST FOR
BARBER. AND STARTING OUT. AND
THEN THIS IS JUST MY EXPERIENCE
MY LAST SIGH THIS IS MY
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH OTHER
STATES WHAT HAS MADE FOR
SUCCESSFUL CHANGE WERE HAVE
STATES HAD PROBLEMS. THAT THEY
DID NOT PERCEIVE THE FIRST ONE
IS. JUST I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO HAVE A THOUGHTFUL PROCESS
WHICH APPEARS LIKE YOU'RE
ALREADY DOING TAKE THE TIME TO
DO THE RIGHT THING. WHEN STATES
DO THINGS TOO QUICKLY. THERE%
SEEMS TO BE A LOT LACK OF.
LOOKING AT HOW ALL THE- PLAYERS
FIT INTO IT. THIS SECOND ONE
HAVING A SINGLE AGENCY TO
PROVIDE. OVERSIGHT OVER ALL THE
ASPECTS. WHEN YOU HAVE TOO MANY
AGENCIES INVOLVED THAT'S ONE
THING I'VE SEEN A LOT OF STATES
LIKE IT TOO MANY AGENCIES
INVOLVED. AND WHAT HAPPENS IS
YOUR THINGS THAT FALL TO THE
CRACKS THERE'S NO NOBODY WANTS
TO BE. NOBODY'S ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ANYONE THING AND SO HAVING ONE
AGENCY HAVING OVERSIGHT. AND
THEN UNDERSTANDING OBVIOUSLY
THE FINANCIAL ISSUES FOR ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS. ANTICIPATING
THAT COMING IN WITH A SOLUTION
TO SAY WE UNDERSTAND. FOR THE
STUDENTS FOR THE SCHOOLS FOR
THAT OVERSIGHT AGENCY THERE
WILL BE SOME FINANCIAL
CONSIDERATIONS. AND WHAT DO WE
FOUR SEE IF YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
TO GIVE THEM THE ANSWER BUT
WHAT WE FORESEE. AS BEING AWAY
TO MEDICATE THOSE FEARS. AND
THAT'S ALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF FOR THE TESTIMONY OF I DID
HAVE A COUPLE FOLLOW QUESTIONS.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT RECIPROCITY
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN THE STATES.
ARE THEY BASED ON ANY CERTAIN.
REQUIREMENTS SAME TYPE OF TEXT
BOOKS US INTENT OF CURRICULUM
HOW IS THAT RIGHT RECIPROCITY
SO IT WORKED OUT REALLY IT IS
THERE IS A MAP THAT THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL COUNCIL STATE
LEGISLATURES HAS MAYBE HE'LL BE
ABLE TO SHOW IT AT SOME POINT.
AND IT SHOWS THE DESPITE THE
VAST DISPARITY OF ALL AMONGST
THE STATE'S SOME STATES WILL
ALLOW YOU TO COME IN AND YOUR
WORK YOUR WORK HISTORY HE
WORKED FOR I THINK CALIFORNIA'S
LAST THREE THREE OUT THE LAST
FIVE YEARS AS A COSMETOLOGY
ANOTHER STATE THAT COUNTS. SOME
STATES LIKE OHIO MAKE YOU
RETEST NO MATTER HOW LONG YOU
WORKED IF YOU WORK FOR THIRTY
OUT OF THIRTY YEARS YOU KNOW ON
THE FIELD YOU HAVE TO RETEST ON
NATIONAL EXAM IT'S ALL OVER THE
BOARD SOME STATES WILL MAKE YOU
MAKE UP THE HOURS SO IF YOU
WORK IN TEXAS FOR EXAMPLE WORKS
AT THAT AS AN HOUR. AND A YOU
GO TO A STATE THAT IS EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS THEY MAY MAKE YOU
GO BACK TO SCHOOL FOR EIGHT
HUNDRED HOURS. TODAY AND TAKE A
AN EXAM IT'S VERY VERY SICK.
WIDELY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THERE'S NO SET METHOD. AND YOU
TALK ABOUT EXAMS. IS THERE ANY
TYPE OF. I'D NATIONAL EXAMINE
EACH OF THESE FIELDS IN WHICH
ONE CAN THEN. POINT THERE AND
SAY. FORGET HOW MANY. HOURS OF
TRAINING. OR EXPERIENCE YOU
HAVE FORGET HOW MANY TEST YEAH
IT'S THE COMPETENCY BASE THAT
WOULD BE NICE. AND WHAT IS
CALLED THE NATIONAL EXAM RIGHT
NOW WHICH IS THE AND I SEE EXAM
AS CURRENTLY ONLY IN TWENTY
EIGHT STATES OF THE START
REALLY EVERY STATE UNTIL WE GET
AN EXAM THAT IS ACCEPTED BY. IN
THE VAST MAJORITY OF STATES
RIGHT NOW I'M SOME STATES
CREATE THEIR OWN EXAM SOME
STATES HAVE PRACTICAL SOME
STATES DOWN. IT'S A THERE'S NO
CONSENSUS AROUND THE COUNTRY OF
HOW TESTING IS HOW EVEN TESTING
IS DONE. SO AND I GUESS IN
CALIFORNIA WE USE THE NATIONAL
EXAMS AS AND I SWEET TO ME. AND
SO WHY NOT JUST THAT. YOU KNOW
IT. I GUESS TEACH FOR THE TEST
IS NOT THE RIGHT WAY TO POSE
THE QUESTION BUT- WHAT WHY WHY
NOT JUST HAVE. A SET THE
STANDARD OF PASSING THAT
NATIONAL EXAM. AND IF YOU CAN
DO THAT JUST. IF YOU IF YOU
WANT TO BE A LAWYER IN
CALIFORNIA YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
TO LAW SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT TELL I'M NERVOUS AT THE
PAST YOU HAVE TO PASS THE STATE
BAR. RIGHT AND THEN YOU CAN
PRACTICE AND- DO SOME STATES
PROVIDE THAT AS AN ALTERNATIVE
SIMPLY THAT YOU PASSED THE
STANDARDS. AND THEREFORE YOU
CAN YOU GET THE LICENSE. THAT'S
VERY LIMITED SO THERE IS BEEN A
LOT OF TALK AT THE CONSORTIUM
GROUPS. ABOUT CONTACT LAW WHICH
IS THE BEST WAY PROBABLY TO
ACHIEVE THAT I'M A NURSE AND WE
OPERATE AT A NURSING CONTACT.
THIRTY FOUR STATES PARTICIPATE
IF I WERE TO MOVE TO ANY OF THE
OTHER STATES IT DUMPED US PAID.
I WOULD HAVE OTHER ENTRY
REQUIREMENTS SO. IT'S NOT IT'S
NOT A THERE'S NOT IT THERE IS
NOT A NATIONAL EXAM THAT EVERY
STATE EXCEPT YET. I WILL SAY
THAT SO IS THERE IS THE ABILITY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO EAT I MEAN.
SO CERTAINLY WERE SUBJECT TO
FEDERAL STANDARDS. THAT COME
INTO PLAY BUT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE THERE'S A LOT. IS THE ROOM
FOR CALIFORNIA TOOK TO CARPET
SOME PATH IN TERMS OF
COMPETENCY AS THE STANDARD NOT
EDUCATION. YOU COULD CARVE YOUR
OWN PATH IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THE OTHER FORTY NINE STATES ARE
GONNA ACCEPTED FOR ENTRY FROM
I'LL FROM SOMEBODY FROM
CALIFORNIA THAT THAT'S MY WHOLE
POINT THERE THERE IS SUCH A
SORT OF SOVEREIGNTY ISSUE IN
ALL THE STATES THAT IT'S HARD
TO MAKE EVERYBODY. COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE
I HEAR THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
ARGUMENT ALL THE TIME THAT I
GET A DRIVER'S LICENSE AND I
LIVE IN KANSAS I GET A DRIVER'S
LICENSE IN KANSAS AND I CAN
DRIVE IN ALL FIFTY STATES.
THAT'S THROUGH CONTACT LAW AND
THAT IS THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
IF THIS INDUSTRY CAN EMBRACE IT
WOULD I THINK I'M WOULD. HELP
THE INDUSTRY IF EVERYBODY COULD
AGREE THAT IF I'M SAFE AND OF
THAT I'M ALSO SAFE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE. BUT
THAT'S NOT WHERE IT IS TODAY I
WILL SAY THAT IT'S NOT THERE IN
HOUSTON AND I'M SENSITIVE TO
THE RECIPROCITY ISSUE BUT IT IS
ABOUT TRYING TO PROVIDE THE
RIGHT STANDARDS FOR THOSE WHO
WANT TO PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA
MOST OF WHOM ARE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS OKAY COULD YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT I WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT. PRIVATE VERSUS PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN THESE FIELDS. WHO
IS WHO IS WHO WHO'S TRAINING
WHO'S EDUCATING. I IT AND IF
YOU HAVE ANY KNOWLEDGE THERE
YOU COULD SHARED BE GREAT. SO
ARE YOU SPEAKING WHEN HE SAID
PRIVATE EDUCATION VERSUS A
PUBLIC ARE USED WHEN YOU SAY
PUBLIC ARE YOU TALKING THE
COLLEGE TYPE EDUCATION OR THE
HIGH SCHOOL BASED PROGRAMS I'M
DONE TALKING ABOUT EITHER ONE
THAT. THAT THAT AS I UNDERSTAND
IT SO MANY OF THE- THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OFFERED IN THIS AREA IN
CALIFORNIA ARE DONE THROUGH
PRIVATE. ENTITIES FOR PROFIT
NONPROFIT. THAT THE VERY FEW
WERE DONE THROUGH OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
CERTAINLY PUBLIC SCHOOLS. IS
THAT CONSISTENT WITH WHAT YOU
UNDERSTAND HAPPENS AROUND THE
COUNTRY THAT THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT HAPPENS AROUND THE
COUNTRY EVERYBODY HAS SOME MIX
OF THOSE TWO THINGS A LOT OF
STATES ALSO HAVE HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. SO STUDENT COULD
ARGUE THEY GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AND GET THEIR
COSMETOLOGY LICENSE AND GO TO
WORK AND MOST OF THOSE STATES.
I WOULD SAY THERE'S NO. REAL
ANSWER HERE IT IS DEPENDENT ON.
THERE'S GOOD SCHOOLS. SCHOOLS I
MEAN JUST LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE
THERE ARE THERE'S GOOD YOU KNOW.
IF THE STATE REALLY WANTED TO
CLEAN AND THAT THEY WOULDN'T BE
FROM MAKING A NEW. PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IT WOULD BE GETTING
BETTER OVERSIGHT TO SEE
SOMEBODY AND SOME TYPE OF A
AGENCY THAT COULD. THE BAD
SCHOOLS AND GET RID OF THEM
GIVE THEM THAT OVERSIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT BECAUSE THERE'S
GOOD SCHOOLS ARE BAD SCHOOLS.
IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM THE
ONE THING THAT THEY DO BENEFIT
FROM IS THAT BENEFIT FROM A
STANDARDIZED CURRICULUM. AND
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. SEEMS
TO HAVE A THE STRUCTURE AROUND
THEM THE SCHOOL STRUCTURE
AROUND THEM EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT IS HAPPENING FROM AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LEVEL SEEM TO
HELP THEM GET PEOPLE THROUGH
AND AT A CERTAIN REGIMENTED
SORT OF WAY BUT AYE AYES PLACE
IN GOOD SCHOOLS BAD SCHOOLS
GOOD TEACHERS BAD TEACHERS AND
THAT THE PROBLEM IN MY MIND
ISN'T HE DOES IT IT'S WHO. WHO
HAS OVERSIGHT TO REGULATE THE
GOOD AND THE BAD. I GOT SHOULD
THERE AYE AYE THERE. I THINK
FOR ME AT LEAST IT'S A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN THAT YEAH IT'S
ALSO ABOUT. KEEPING COSTS LOW
SO THE PRIVATE SECTOR PROGRAMS
THAT BY THEIR VERY NATURE ARE
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE THAN IF
THEY WERE OFFERED A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO I THINK THERE F
THERE'S A FEW MORE THE ISSUES
INVOLVED IN. IN THAT CHOICE AND.
AT THE END AND IT DOES. GIVEN
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE INTERESTED
IN PROFESSIONAL CAREERS OUR
CAREERS IN THESE FIELDS AND
GIVEN HOW MUCH HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE ENROLLING IN THOSE PRIVATE
COURSES HERE IN OUR STATE AND I
LOOK FOR MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT AS WE GO FORWARD WITH OUR-
HEARING PROCESS. IT SEEMS LIKE
THAT IT IT OUR OUR PUBLIC AREAS
OUR PUBLICATIONS IS THE CANARY
COLLEGES FAILING TO PROVIDE
THAT CURRICULUM OPPORTUNITY.
THAT THAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING
A BETTER JOB WE HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. CALIFORNIA AND ARE
THEY BEING RESPONSIVE TO THE-
THE INTEREST THAT'S OUT THERE.
THE I. D. IT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE DONE FOR THE
LAST ELEVEN YEARS AS I'VE DONE
A LOT OF IN SCHOOL ON TRAININGS
ALL GO OUT AND DO INFECTION
CONTROL AND- ON TALK ABOUT
CHEMICAL SAFETY IN THE SCHOOL
SO I'VE BEEN IN BOTH
ENVIRONMENTS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TYPE ENVIRONMENT. EVEN
HIGH SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT AND IN
THE PRIVATE SCHOOL SECTOR AYE I
DON'T HAVE ANY REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE- PUBLIC SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT
IS ANY LESS VALUABLE THAN
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE- PRIVATE
COMMITTEE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S A COST DIFFERENTIAL.
AND BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
ALSO THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT. AMOUNT. THERE IS
THAT THERE'S NOT AS MUCH
AVAILABILITY OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM SO PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO DO IT TODAY. YOU KNOW
THEY CAN'T GET IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM NON GO TO THE
PRIVATE SCHOOL SYSTEM RIGHT AND
THAT RAISES SOME OF THE AREA OF
NURSING. IF THEY'RE NURSING
PUBLIC NURSING OPERAS COOLS ARE
FULL. YOU UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO CHOOSE A MORE
EXPENSIVE ALTERNATIVE THEY
COULD ARGUE. THERE'S A HIGHER
QUALITY LEVEL BUT WHATEVER THE
CASE. IT'S OUT OF AN ABSENCE OF
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE PUBLIC
TRACK. AND IT SEEMS LIKE THAT
THAT MAY BE A AT PLAY HERE AS
WELL. LET ME FINALLY ASK YOU
ABOUT THE SLIDE THAT YOU
PRESENTED ON RISK VERSUS
CURRICULUM. WHERE YOU HAD THE
UPSIDE DOWN TRIANGLE SHOWING
THAT FOR THE FOR THOSE.
PROCEDURES THAT ARE MOST AT
RISK WOULD PROVIDE THE LOWEST
LEVEL OF CURRICULUM WHAT WHY IS
THAT IF HEALTH AND SAFETY IS
THE FOR STANDARD THAT I THINK
WE ALL. MUTUALLY SHARE IN TERMS
OF. MAKING SURE THOSE WHO
PRACTICE. THESE TRADES ARE
DOING IN A SAFE MANNER. WHY IS
IT THAT THE CURRICULUMS UPSIDE
DOWN IN YOUR VIEW. THAT IS NOT
A QUESTION THAT I FEEL LIKE I
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS I FEEL LIKE. I'M
ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS TO THAT.
IS THAT IF I WANT TO DO NAILS.
FIVE I DON'T KNOW I HAVE TO SIT
THROUGH. A HUNDRED HOURS A HAIR
I DON'T KNOW I HAVE TO DO THAT
IF I WANT TO DO NOW IS I SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DO NAILS AND DO IT
SAFELY AND MOVE ON. BUT I DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT HOW THAT HAS
OCCURRED I'M NOT SURE OVER TIME
HOW THE CURRICULUM HAS GROWN SO
MUCH IN THE HAIR INDUSTRY IN
EIGHT STANDARD COSMETOLOGY
LICENSE I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER
FOR THAT. OKAY ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS. A DECISION YET THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND CHOCOLATE
SHOULD BE TO SIMILAR THAT THE
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
COMBINATION OF THE CURRICULUM
THOUGH GIVEN THE KIND OF
SCHOLARSHIPS AND FINANCIAL AID
THAT ALL COMES WITH AN
ASSOCIATE OF IT SO. YOU DID YOU
WOULD YOU WOULD YOU AGREE AT
THE OBSERVATION THAT PERHAPS
THAN THE SCHOOLS MAY BE PUTTING
UP THE STRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
FOCUS ON STUDENT GOING TO THE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES THAT THE
STRUCTURE IN PLACE FOR
CURRICULUM. HELPS TO PROMOTE
THAT THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER
THING I'M NOT REALLY PREPARED I
DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW I DO KNOW
THAT PROGRAMS WHERE. IN STATES
THAT I'VE WORKED AND WHERE THEY
HAVE. LOWER OUR OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ENTRY. WHEN STUDENTS CANNOT
GET FINANCIAL AID THOSE ARE NOT
POPULAR CHOICES THAT I CAN SAY
THAT THAT IS NOT DEPEND ON
POPULAR CHOICES BECAUSE- OF
THE- THE FINANCIAL ASPECT OF
THEM. SURE EVEN THOUGH. THERE
ARE STATES WHERE THERE'S A-
THERE ARE STATES WHERE. BECAUSE
THE HOURS ARE SO LOW. IN SOME
OF THE FOR EXAMPLE FOR NAILS.
ARGUABLY THE IT SHOULD BE
SOMETHING SOME THEY COULD PAY
FOR YOU KNOW IN A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME THERE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT DO. THEY SELL
FINANCE THEMSELVES THAT KIND OF
THING BUT I. I CAN'T ANSWER FOR
WHY THE CURRICULUM GREW THE WAY
IT DID. YOU KNOW I HAVE NO
ANSWERS. SURE ABOUT ANY OF
OBSERVATION THERE MAY BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO ANY OF THE ISSUES
WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AS CERTAINLY IN
THE CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS AND WITHIN
THESE INDUSTRIES I THINK I SAW
ON THEIR STATISTICS THAT IS
ALMOST THREE TO ONE FOR ASIAN
LANGUAGES. WE DON'T NECESSARILY
COLLECT THE STATISTICS ON THAT
OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF LICENSED
INDIVIDUALS BUT UP THE ACTUAL
TEST TAKERS THAT THREE THE ALL
THE RATIOS ALMOST THREE TO ONE
IN TERMS OF TAKING THESE EXAMS
IN THE NATION LANGUAGE THERE BY
THE- HIGH PERCENTAGE OF ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS MANY INTO
OFTENTIMES RECENT IMMIGRANTS.
SOME OF THESE OTHER COSTS
BEARERS COULD ALSO BE IN EFFECT
TO DO YOU HAVE ANY OBSERVATIONS
WITH AFFECTED THE INTERACTIVE
BETTER ABLE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION FROM WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IN ABOUT A THEY I THINK
THEY GET THEIR LIFE THEIR EXAM
IN FIVE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
FIVE EIGHT DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
AND ONE THING I WILL SAY IS
THAT YOU HAVE A UNIQUE PROBLEM
NOT A PROBLEM UNIQUE SITUATION
IN CALIFORNIA SOMETHING THAT
REALLY NO OTHER STATE HAS YOU
HAVE I GO TO RURAL STATES OR I
GO TO STATES THAT ARE. VERY
HIGHLY POPULATED SMALL STATES
WITH HIGH POPULATION BASES.
EVERYBODY IS A LITTLE BIT OF
BUT YOU GUYS REALLY HAVE. THE
BEST OF BOTH WORLDS ARE THE
WORST OF BOTH WORLDS FROM A
LEGISLATIVE STANDPOINT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE SO MUCH REAL AREA I
THINK PEOPLE THE OTHER FORTY
NINE STATES. FORGET HOW MUCH
ROLL ERA YOU HAVE LIKE TO DO IS
DRIVE BETWEEN. TWO YOU KNOW
POPULATION CENTERS AND YOU'LL
SEE HOW MUCH REAL AREA HAVE TO
DEAL WITH. YOU HAVE IMMIGRANTS
FROM FAR MORE COUNTRIES THAN
ALMOST VERY IN A VERY FEW
STATES HAVE AS MANY IMMIGRANTS
AS YOU DO. AND YOU'RE DEALING
WITH RURAL AND POPULOUS BASED
AM. ISSUES SO I THINK. YOU GUYS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AS YOU
SAID IN THE BEGINNING TO SORT
OF BE THE LEADERS AND ALL THIS
IS WHY I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO. THINK IT THROUGH IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU PUT FORWARD
BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE UNIQUE.
ISSUES WITH. IN THERE ARE
STATES WILL ONLY GIVE THEIR
EXAMINE ENGLISH THERE'S LOTS OF
THEM THERE ARE A LOT OF STATES
IT WILL ONLY GIVE THAT. EXAMINE
ENGLISH BECAUSE- IN THEIR MINDS
GOT TO SPEAK ENGLISH WELL LOOK.
I CAN FUNCTION IN THE COMMUNITY
AND LOTSOF I CAN FUNCTION A
LOT THE COMMUNITIES HERE AND
NEVER SPEAK A WORD OF ENGLISH
AND BE PERFECTLY FUNCTIONAL.
AND DO MY JOB SAFELY SO. TO
YOUR QUESTION ADAM MIGHT BE
BETTER ABLE TO ANSWER IT BUT
I'VE CAN ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP
ALL THINGS AND YOU KNOW. AND
ALSO TO HAVE SORT OF A VISION
FOR WHAT OTHER PEOPLE WHO LOOK
IN THE CALIFORNIA SEE. IT'S
PRETTY EVEN I HAVE A TON OF
POWER HERE RIGHT AND I THINK
YOU KNOW THAT AND I THINK THAT
USED HARD JUDICIOUSLY. BECAUSE
IT DOES FILTER I STARTED MY
PRESENTATION MEANT TO CALL MY
NATIONAL PRESENTATIONS THIS
YEAR. AND I SHOWED MAPS AND I
SAID THIS IS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR THIS IS TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR THIS IS TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AND ONE NEXT
HOLY READ. ONE NAP IS READ A
LITTLE BIT OF GREEN AND THE
FIRST SCREEN STATE. OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEN TWENTY
TWELVE AND ALL PATCHWORK IN IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WORDS ALL GREEN
AND A PLACE TO STATES THAT
AREN'T. AND THAT WAS. A
LEGISLATION DENIED STATE THAT
HOW QUICKLY IT HAPPENED AND SO.
THE POWER THAT. YOU KNOW STATES
LIKE YOURS HAVE. MAKING
DECISIONS TO THE TO THE CAN
FOLLOW SO. THANK YOU TO USE ITS
USE THAT POWERS YOU KNOW ANNA
IF THOUGHTFUL WAY. VERY GOOD AT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY MISTRUSTING WATCHES
STICK AROUND AND SEE THAT
THERE'S FURTHER CONVERSATION WE
COULD HAVE. BUT I WANT TO NOW
WELCOME THE ADAM HIGGINBOTTOM
HERE TO. OUR HEARING ROOM
YOU'RE THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NEVADA STATE
BOARD OF COSMETOLOGY. WE HAVE A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN THIS FIELD
WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO.
SPEAK TO US THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OFFER. MY NAME IS ADAM
HIGGINBOTHAM I AM THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE ABOUT US THE
POOR COSMETOLOGY. PRIOR TO THAT
I WAS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE WEST VIRGINIA STATE BAR
PERSON COSMETOLOGIST. I'M NOT A
LICENSED PARTICIPANT NOR HAVE
BEEN TRAINED IN. ANY BEAUTY
SERVICE TECHNIQUES. I DO HAVE
ELEVEN YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WITH
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING BOARDS.
AND IN THOSE ELEVEN YEARS I'VE
BEEN PART OF TEAMS. THAT HAVE
USE TECHNOLOGY TO DELIVER FAST
APPLICATION PROCESSING TIMES.
TO COLLECT BETTER DATA DURING
OUR INSPECTIONS. TO IMPROVE OUR
CONSUMER AWARENESS BY
DISPLAYING SO ON INSPECTION
RESULTS ON A WEBSITE IN REAL
TIME. OF WE USE TECHNOLOGY TO
DEVELOP AN API WITH THE CONTACT
THE CONTRACTED STATE VENDOR. TO
STREAMLINE NEVADA'S TESTING TO
LICENSING PROCESS. AND WE USE
TECHNOLOGY TO DELIVER TO
ORGANIZE OUR DATA. THAT WE
COLLECT SO WE CAN REVIEW
REPORTS TO IMPROVE OUR CONSUMER
AWARENESS AND TO IMPROVE THE
DELIVERY. OF OUR TESTING
LICENSING AND INSPECTION AND
EDUCATION SERVICES. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING A LITTLE INFORMATION
ABOUT A PROJECT IN ABOUT HIS
BEEN WORKING ON. THE STAFF HAS
BEEN WORKING ON A PROJECT TO
IDENTIFY THE RISKS IN BEAUTY
SERVICES. IT IS TO IS MY OUR TO
BE ONE OF THE OF THE
CONTRIBUTORS TO BE
COMMUNICATING ABOUT THE PROJECT
TODAY. BEFORE YOU. YOU HAVE TO
REMIND ME. HI SINCE FEBRUARY OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
NEVADA STATE BOARD
COSMETOLOGY'S BEEN WORKING ON A
PROJECT TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
RISKS IN NINETEEN COMMON BEAUTY
SERVICES AND THESE ARE BEAUTY
SERVICES THAT A NEWLY MARKET
PARTICIPANTS. SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PERFORM SAFELY AND WITH BASIC
UNDERSTANDING OF THE TECHNIQUES
BEHIND. AS OF OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THERE BEEN
MORE THAN THIRTY PROJECT
POLITICA COLLABORATORS WITH
OVER FIVE HUNDRED YEARS OF
LICENSE EXPERIENCE. AND THEY
REPRESENT SIXTEEN DIFFERENT
STATE JURISDICTIONS. THE
COLLABORATORS HAVE INCLUDED
INDUSTRY REGULATORS SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS THEORY EXAM
CONTENT DEVELOPERS PRACTICAL
EXAM RAIDERS LICENSED INDUSTRY
PARTICIPANTS IN LICENSED
INSTRUCTORS IN THE FIELDS OF
COSMETOLOGY HAIR DESIGN
AESTHETICS NOW TECHNOLOGY AND
INDUSTRY DISTRIBUTOR. THE
PROJECT COLLABORATORS HAVE HELD
SEVERAL MEETINGS WORK PRODUCT
MEETINGS WHERE WE'VE WE'VE
WHERE WE HAVE REVIEWED HAIR
NAIL AND SKIN CARE SERVICES.
EARLY IT IS AS ESTIMATED THAT
WE HAVE SPENT OVER TWO THOUSAND
HOURS WORKING ON THIS PROJECT.
NEVADA STATE BORDER
COSMETOLOGY'S A SELF SUPPORTING
BOARD THAT IS FULLY ON THOMAS.
AND WE CONSTANTLY USE
TECHNOLOGY TO IMPROVE THE
DELIVERY OF OUR SERVICES. THE
IMPLEMENTED TECHNOLOGICAL
IMPROVEMENTS HAVE LED TO OUR
EFFICIENCIES. THAT HAS CREATED
THE TIME FOR THE STAFF TO WORK
ON THIS PROJECT. ALONG WITH OUR
FOR OUR BOARD STRUCTURES IT
LEADS PER HAS PROVIDED US WITH
THE FLEXIBILITY NEEDED SO WE
COLLABORATE WITH OUR PARTNERS
ON THIS PROJECT. THE VOTE IS
EXPECTED TO RELEASE TO THE
PUBLIC WITH SOME LIMITATIONS
THE CONCLUSIONS OF THIS PROJECT
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY.
YOU'RE THE FIRST BODY TO SEE
THIS. CLICK CLICK. THE PROJECT
STARTED OUT WITH SEVEN
OBJECTIVES THE FIRST OBJECTIVE
WAS TO IDENTIFY COMMON BEAUTY
SERVICES THE BEAUTY SERVICE
INDUSTRY NEOPHYTES SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PERFORM UNDER CURRENT
COSMETOLOGY LICENSING STRUCTURE.
pADVANCED SERVICES AND
TECHNIQUES. THE SECOND
OBJECTIVE IS WITH IS TO LIST
THE STEPS IN SUB STEPS NEEDED
IN ORDER TO COMPLETE THAT
BEAUTY SERVICE. THE THIRD
OBJECTIVE WAS TO IDENTIFY THE
TOOLS AND IMPLEMENTS THAT WE
USED IN EACH OF THOSE SERVICES
THE FORCE OF FOURTH OBJECTIVE
IDENTIFIED THE PRODUCTS USED IN
EACH OF THOSE SERVICES AND AT
EACH STEP ALONG THE WAY OF THAT
SERVICE. A FIST THE FIFTH
OBJECTIVE IDENTIFIES THE AREA
OF RISK FOR EACH STEP IN SUB
STEP OF THAT SERVICE. THIS SIX
OBJECTIVE IDENTIFIED WHETHER
THE RISK WAS AN INJURY OR
INFECTION. AND THE SEVENTH
OBJECTIVE IDENTIFIED THE WRIST
OUTCOME POSSIBILITIES. AFTER WE
IDENTIFY THE COMMON HERE NOW
AND SKIN SERVICES AND WE WERE
ABLE TO COMPLETE THE STEPS AND
SUB STEPS NEEDED TO PERFORM
THAT SERVICE. THE COLLABORATORS
THEN ANSWERED. FOR EACH STEP IN
EACH SUB STEP THE SAME SIX
QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. WE ASKED WHAT TOOL
OR EMPLOYMENT WAS USED AT THIS
SPECIFIC. POINT IN THE SERVICE
WHAT PRODUCT WAS USED AT THIS
POINT IN THE SERVICE WHAT
CHEMICALS ARE MIXED TO APPLIED
AT THAT SPECIFIC POINT IN THE
SERVICE. WHAT PROTECTIVE GEAR
SHOULD BE WORN BY THE LICENSE
PROFESSIONAL OR BY THE
CONSUMER. AT THAT SPECIFIC.
POINT A SERVICE. WE IDENTIFY WE
ASK WHAT ARE THE RISKS TO THE
CONSUMER AT THAT SPECIFIC POINT
IN ORDER THE REST TO THE BEAUTY
SERVICE PROFESSIONAL. AT THAT
THE SERVICE POINT. THE DATA
COLLECTED FROM THIS PROJECT WAS
PUT INTO A SIMPLE EQUATION BY
TAKING THE NUMBER. OF SERVICES.
THE NUMBER OF SERVICE STEPS
NEEDED TO COMPLETE. OF THE I'M
SORRY THE SIMPLE QUESTIONS BY
TAKING THE NUMBER OF THE
SERVICE THE SERVICE IS NUMBER
STEPS OR SUBSTANCE THERE WERE
IDENTIFIED AS RISKS. AND
DIVIDED INTO THE TOTAL NUMBER
STEPS ARE SUCH STEPS FOR THE
SERVICE. TO ESTABLISH A WRIST
PERCENTAGE THAT WE CAN HOPE
THAT WE HOPE LEADS TO IMPROVED
CONSUMER AWARENESS. THE WRIST
PERCENTAGES NOT A PERCENTAGE OF
AN INJURY OR INFECTION ACTUALLY
OCCURRING. IT SHOWS THE WRIST
PERCENTAGE INDICATES THE NUMBER
OF AREAS. WITHIN A SERVICE THAT
IF THAT PARTICULAR STEP IS NOT
PERFORMED PROPERLY. WHAT ARE
THE OUTCOMES. IN THE NEXT FEW
SLIDES ALSO WE'LL SHOW YOU TWO
ON RELEASE SERVICE INFO SHEETS.
THAT IDENTIFIED THE FACIAL
SERVICE AND EYELASH EXTENSION
SERVICE. SO ON THIS SERVICE
INFO SHE YOU'LL SEE. THIS PART
IS JUST ONE PART ONE OF A THREE
SECTION SERVICE INFO SHEET. HI
THIS SERVICE SERVICE AND SO IN
FOR INFO SHE JUST BROKE DOWN A
THREE SECTIONS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THIS PRESENTATION THIS FIRST
SECTION CONTAINS THE RIBS NOW
IF YOU NOTICE IN THE PERCENTAGE
INDICATOR ON THE RIGHT CORNER.
IT IDENTIFIES THAT THEIR SIXTY
PERFECT 64% OF THE FACIAL
SERVICES STEPS OR SUBSTANCE
COULD POSE A RISK TO A CONSUMER
IF THE STEPPER SUB STEP IS NOT
PROPERLY PERFORM. AS WE
TRANSITION INTO. THE OTHER AREA
THE INFO SHE DECEMBER SHEET
IDENTIFIES THE PARTICULAR TOOLS
AND IMPLEMENT SOME PRODUCTS
THAT ARE USED. AT THAT MOMENT
OF THE SERVICE. AND THEN
TRANSITIONING INTO. THE THIRD
PART OF THE INFO SHEET YOU'LL
SEE IT BREAKS DOWN THE STEPS IN
SUB STEPS NEEDED. TO PERFORM
THE FACIAL SERVICE AND THE SUB
STEPS THAT ARE HIGHLIGHTED IN
RED REPRESENT THAT IF THIS
SERVICE AREA IS PERFORMED
IMPROPERLY. IT COULD POSE A
RISK TO A CONSUMER. AND I HAVE
THE SAME BREAKDOWN FOR THE
EYELASH EXTENSION THIS
PERCENTAGE I'M SORRY THIS
PERCENTAGE IS AT FIFTY NINE
PERCENT. BREAKDOWN AND IF YOU
CAN SEE ON THE SERVICE IN FOR
SHEET SHOWS INFECTION RELATED
CROSS CONTAMINATION IN THE
POSSIBLE OUTCOMES OF THAT
INFECTION THE INJURY OR DAMAGE
RELATED TO A SPECIFIC SERVICE.
AND IT OUTLINES THE DAMAGE SURE
THE INJURY WHETHER IT'S WHAT
THE INJURY COULD BE. RELATED TO
THAT SPECIFIC SERVICE. AND THEN
THERE ARE THE CLIENT
CONSULTATION PART WHICH IS
WHERE. IT'S THE IT'S A LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS KNOWLEDGE BASE
THAT SIN IS THAT THEY HAVE AN
IN INSIDE THE BRAIN THAT IS
RETRIEVED FOR PERFORMING A SCAN
ANALYSIS. IT'S ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS TO A CAN'T TO THEIR
TO THEIR CUSTOMER. THAT WOULD
HELP IDENTIFY PRODUCT ALLARD
ALLERGIES OR CURRENT MEDICS
MEDICINE TO MAKE COUNTERACT
WITH THE PRODUCTS THAT A
CONSUMER MAY BE RECEIVING. ON
THEIR SKIN. AND ALSO IF THE
PROPER ANALYSIS ISN'T DONE THEN
A SERVICE CAN BE PERFORMED ON
IMPAIRED SKIN INTEGRITY WHICH
COULD RESULT IN. A PRODUCT
INGREDIENT GETTING INSIDE OF A
CUT OR A WOUND AND THAT
MEASUREMENT. THERE ARE TOO MANY
VARIABLES AT THAT POINT. AGAIN
TOOLS IMPLEMENTS ARE LISTED FOR
THE EYELASH EXTENSION SERVICE.
ALONG WITH THE STEPS RELATED TO
PERFORM AN EYELASH EXTENSION
SERVICE AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
STEP IN A SUBSTANCE. A STEP IS
A SUPER CATEGORY THAT SAYS THIS
IS THE GENERAL. INFORMATION
IT'S GOING TO BE TALKED ABOUT.
WALLACE SUCH STEP IS TALKING
ABOUT THE ACTUAL DETAILS WITHIN
THAT STEP. SO THE SUB STEP FOR
CRYING FOR THE STEP FOR CLIENT
CONSULTATION YOU CAN SEE HAS
BOTH AN INJURY I CON ALONG WITH
AN INFECTION I CON. NOW YOU'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW FOR THE
EYELASH EXTENSION IF THIS WAS A
HAIR CUT. YOU WILL NOT SEE ANY
RISKS IN A CLIENT CONSULTATION
BECAUSE. SKIN CARE THIS
PARTICULAR SERVICE MAY REQUIRE.
CERTAIN PRELIMINARY QUESTIONS
SHOULD BE IDENTIFIED FOR THIS
TYPE OF SERVICE THAT MIGHT NOT.
BE COMPARABLE TO ANOTHER THE
SERVICE. AS MENTIONED EARLIER
THE PROJECT IS STILL ONGOING
AND THE REPORT ISN'T EXPECTED
TO BE RELEASED UNTIL JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY. HOWEVER WE ARE
WORKING ON THESE TEN HAIR CARE
SERVICES BLOW DRY CAP HIGHLIGHT
CHEMICAL RELAXER CURLING
SERVICE. FORTY FOUR YEAR OLD
HIGHLIGHTS HERE CALLER. CUTTING
PERM WAVE SO AND EXTENSIONS AND
SHAMPOO AND DEEP CONDITIONER
SERVICES. THE SERVICES RELATED
TO HER NOW CARE WILL BE.
MANAGER NOW ENHANCEMENTS
PEDICURE AND POLISH. AND FOR
SKIN CARE WE'LL HAVE EYELASH
EXTENSIONS FACIAL MAKEUP
TWEEZING AND WAXING SERVICES.
THE DATA COLLECTION PROCESS SO
FAR NO HAS LED TO THE
ORGANIZATION OF MORE THAN THREE
THREE THOUSAND DATA POINTS THEY
CAN CAN PINPOINT WHEN AND WHERE
AN ACTUAL TOOL. AND A PRODUCT
IS MET ON A CONSUMER FOR
PARTICULAR BEAUTY SERVICE END
THAT KNOWLEDGE IS APPLIED TO
EXECUTE DOES SO WE CAN FIND OUT
THE STEPS AND SUB STEPS FOR THE
SPEEDY SERVICES. AS THE PROJECT
COLLABORATORS TOOK A STEP BACK
FROM THE DATA THAT WERE
ACTUALLY COLLECTING IN THIS
PROJECT. IT WAS OBSERVE THAT
THIS INFORMATION COULD LEAD TO
FUTURE DEVELOPMENT IN OTHER
AREAS. SOME OF THOSE AREAS SOME
OF THE POTENTIAL USES FOR THIS
INFORMATION COULD. COULD BE IN
SOME CAPACITY USE FOR CONSUMER
AWARENESS INFORMATION WHICH IS
THE PRIMARY DRIVEN PURPOSE OF
THIS DOCUMENT IN THE STATE OF
NEVADA. BUT ALSO COULD BE USED
FOR LEGISLATIVE INFORMATION
EDUCATIONAL CONTENT. DILLON
DEVELOPMENT IMPROVED SANITATION
INSPECTION PROCESS IS THEORY
EXAMINATION CONTENT APPLIED TO
SPECIFIC AREAS OF RISK AND IN
OTHER AREAS THAT WE HAVE NOT
YET LISTED OR IDENTIFIED. MAN
IN CLOSING I LIKE TO THINK YOU
OFFER INVITING. MYSELF AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
COLLABORATORS THAT HAVE WORKED
VERY HARD ON THIS PROJECT. I'M
VERY HONORED TO BE THE ONE
COMMUNICATING SO THANK YOU THE
PERSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT
OF MY APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
AND THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
IN NEVADA. SO I WANT TO STRETCH
YOU A LITTLE BIT HERE AND WE
HAD A CONVERSATION WITH LESLIE
EARLIER ABOUT A COUPLE OF AREAS
THAT. YA ARE RAISING ISSUES
THAT WERE TAKEN A LOOK AT AND I
WANTED TO SEE IF YOU WANTED AT
TALK ABOUT HOW NEVADA'S
HANDLING SOME OF THOSE SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES. WHAT IS THE
TYPICAL EDUCATION REQUIREMENT
IN NEVADA FOR COSMETOLOGY
LICENSE. THE OUR REQUIREMENT IS
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS FOR
COSMETOLOGY ANY YOU HEARD
LESLIE TALK ABOUT THE RISK
VERSUS THE CURRICULUM ISSUE.
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THAT ADD ANY
COMMENTS ABOUT THAT. I THINK
THAT THIS PROJECT IS A GOOD
FOUNDATION TO WORK ON DETAILING
AREAS OF WHAT LESLIE WAS
TALKING ABOUT ON HER INVERTED
PYRAMID. OF I THINK THE
INFORMATION IT'S THE SAME TYPE
OF INFORMATION JUST
COMMUNICATING DIFFERENT MANNER.
OUR A AND SHE I'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT IN SOME STATES THEY HAVE A
MUCH MORE NARROW LICENSE IN
THESE FIELDS AND A GREAT
EXAMPLE I THINK WAS THE ONE.
THAT FOCUSED ON NAILS WITH THE
LEAST AMOUNT OF FAT TRAINING
FOR CERTIFICATIONS THAT RIGHT
LESLIE. HAVE YOU EXAMINED THAT
AS AN AS A- CENTRAL PRACTICE
INTO THAT AT ALL. MORE NARROW
LICENSES PROVIDING EASIER
ACCESS. FOR THE TRAINING
EDUCATION AND THEN PRACTICE.
I'M SORRY ARE YOU REFERRING TO
MORE SPUR NICHE LICENSES ARE
SPECIALLY LICENSES YES YOU WE
HAVE AN ABOUT A IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WE IMPLEMENTED A MAKE
UP ARTISTS CERTIFICATION A
THREADING. CERTIFICATION AS
WELL AND A THREADING
ESTABLISHMENT CERTIFICATION
WHICH IS A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
FEE FILL OUT THE APPLICATION.
AND THEY CAN PERFORM THOSE
TYPES OF SERVICES HE SAID
THREADING WHAT IS THAT
THREADING IS SEE TECHNIQUE WE
USE THREAD. TO USE THE THREAD.
ROLLING ACROSS THIS THE EYEBROW
TO REMOVE YOUR HAIR AND THE
FROM EUROPE. OKAY GOOD LEARN
SOMETHING IT'S AN ANCIENT
TECHNIQUE FROM WHAT I'VE BEEN
TOLD IT'S IT GOES BACK OKAY
LONG BEFORE WE WERE HERE OKAY
FAIR ENOUGH THANKS FOR SHARING
THAT. DO YOU A IN TERMS OF THAT
WITH WHERE IT IS IN NEVADA.
BEGIN TAKING ADVANTAGE OF YOUR
PRESENCE HERE. OUT WHERE WHERE
DO MOST OF YOUR RESIDENTS GET
TRAINING FOR THESE
CERTIFICATIONS ARE AS IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE PRIVATE SIDE
ANY OBSERVATIONS THERE YOU
COULD SHARE. IN NEVADA WE HAVE
TO SCHOOLS THAT ARE STATE
FUNDED ONE IS IN A VOCATIONAL
SCHOOL THAT'S ONLY FOR. HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. AND THE OTHER
US STATE FUNDED SCHOOLS ANY
PRISON. HIGH I CAN X. CAN
COMMUNICATE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
MY EXPERIENCE IN WEST VIRGINIA.
WHENEVER I WAS I START IN WEST
VIRGINIA TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THERE WERE ELEVEN FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS TO STATE FUNDED SCHOOLS.
I'VE BEEN AWAY FROM FROM THAT
WE MADE SOME LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES IN THE SIX YEARS I WAS
THERE I'VE BEEN GONE FIVE YEARS
NOW. AND SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT WE MADE THERE ARE NOW
FIFTEEN STATE FUNDED SCHOOLS
PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND VOCATIONAL
SCHOOLS. SO IT HAS GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY WHILE THE FOR
PROFIT SCHOOLS IN WEST VIRGINIA
I THINK. HAS REMAINED
RELATIVELY THE SAME AND I CAN
SHARE A CONTACT INFORMATION
WITH YOU AFTER THIS. IF YOU ALL
WOULD LIKE TO LEARN MORE
INFORMATION THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND AN END OF THAT I HAS THE
LICENSES BEEN GOING UP OR DOWN
ANY KENNETH. A TREND THAT YOU
SEE IN YOUR STATE ON THAT.
WE'RE OUR NUMBERS ARE
INCREASING AND LESLIE'S AT THE
SAME NATIONALLY DO YOU KNOW OF
ANY NATIONAL NUMBERS ABOUT. HOW
MANY FOLKS ARE GETTING LICENSES
GOING UP OR DOWN. VERY DEAR
MICROPHONE PLACE VERY
GEOGRAPHICAL SO YOU'LL SEE AND
MORE AND THE MORE RURAL STATES
IT STAYS FAIRLY STABLE IN THE-
TO CLEAN THE STATE TREE SEE
MORE MOVEMENT OF THE YOUNGER
POPULATION YOU'LL SEE THOSE
NUMBERS GOING UP. BUT IN THE
RURAL STATES IT STAYS PRETTY
STATIC. AND GET OUT OF GOING
BACK TO YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
KIND OF A CONFIDENCE MODEL FOR
GETTING A LICENSE OR IS IT
STILL BASED ON HOURS OF
EDUCATION. OR ON THE JOB
EXPERIENCE. OUR HOURS OF FOR
SCHOOL IF YOU LIVE IN A RURAL
AREA THEN WE HAVE AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
COULD BE UTILIZED. AND ANY TO
ANY DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU HAD
ABOUT FOCUSING ON CONFIDENCE
RATHER THAN THE OUR THE
REQUIREMENT AS A STANDARD.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR LEADERSHIP IN
OTHER AREAS BEFORE EXPLORING
THOSE TYPES OF TOPICS. AND
WHEN'S THE LAST TIME YOU
EXAMINED THAT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS THAT WHAT YOU SAID AS A
REQUIREMENT. HAVE YOU DONE ANY
KIND OF EXAMINATION OF THE
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS TO SEE
IF THEY'RE STILL CURRENT AND
APPROPRIATE. WE DID IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE LOWERED.
OUR COSMETOLOGY HOURS FROM.
EIGHTEEN TO SIXTEEN HUNDRED AND
TWO THOUSAND I'M SORRY TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. AND IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE LOWERED
OUR AESTHETICS HOURS IN OUR
HAIR DESIGN HOURS. ARE SIX
HOURS WE WERE REDUCED BY THREE
HUNDRED HOURS. AND THE E.
AESTHETICS BY TWO I'M SORRY IN
THE HAIR DESIGN BY TWO HUNDRED
HOURS. GOOD TO MY AT. CO CHAIR.
SLOW ANY QUESTIONS I HEAR MUCH
SIMILARLY AS A- FOR THE
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT ANY
OBSERVATIONS IDEA OF SIMILAR
SET UP A CHALLENGES WITH THAT
TYPE OF DEMOGRAPHICS ASSUME IN
IN ABOUT A- OF LOVE LICENSEES.
A MOVE WHICH THE CHALLENGES OF
THE CHALLENGES OF THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF QUESTIONS
EARLIER MY BY MY APOLOGIES WAS
WITH RESPECT TO LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AND THE TYPE OF
COMMUNITIES. TYPICALLY WITHIN
THIS INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PREDOMINATELY THAT
OF BEING OF ASIAN DESCENT AND
MIGHT YOU SEE ANY SPECIFIC
CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO
LICENSURE AND THAT OF THE STATE
IN NEVADA. GIVEN THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF BEERS
COMMUNITIES. WE ARE VERY
DIVERSE GROUP. WELL I'M
BRANCHED OUT OF LAS VEGAS AND
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE THAT CAME
OUT BELIEVE IN USA TODAY THAT
SAYS LAS VEGAS IS WHAT AMERICA
CAN EXPECT TO LOOK LIKE IN
TWENTY FIFTY WE'RE VERY DIVERSE
THAN ABOUT A STEEPLE
COSMETOLOGY STAFFS FOR VERY
DIVERSE. I GO THROUGH MY DAY I
CAN BE IN MEETINGS SPEAKING
FIVE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
BECAUSE OUR STAFF CAN SPEAK
KOREAN VIETNAMESE CHINESE AND
SPANISH. IN OUR TESTS ARE
AVAILABLE IN THAT LINK IN ALL
THOSE LANGUAGES AS WELL. AND
WE'RE WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
MAKE SURE ANY OF OUR
INFORMATION THAT WE PRESENT. IN
ENGLISH IS GOING TO BE IN THOSE
SAME LANGUAGES. MEET ME OF A MY
SISTER MAY KEEP MANY MORE
CLARIFIED AND THAT'S THE
BECAUSE THE QUESTION WHICH IS.
ARE THERE SOME UNIQUE
CHALLENGES SPECIFICALLY TO THE
ASIAN COMMUNITY THAT AND SINCE
YOU. MENTIONED THAT THIS IS THE
PREDOMINANT DEMOGRAPHIC OF
OTHER LANGUAGES OTHER THAN
ENGLISH TWO OTHER UNIQUE
CHALLENGES TO THIS COMMUNITY.
WOULD GIVE IN YOUR ROLE IN THE
STATE OF NEVADA. OUR OUR UNIQUE
CHALLENGE WOULD BE THAT WE HAVE
A GROWING DIVERSE POPULATION.
IN OUR EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTES
ARE NOT OFFERING. THE EDUCATION
NEEDED IN THE LANGUAGE THAT ARE.
OUR NEW RESIDENTS NEED. AND IS
THAT THAT THAT'S ONLY THE THIS
IS THE SOLE OBSERVATION THAT
YOU WOULD MAKEGIVING YOUR
CAPACITY OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS
UNLESS THERE'S A SPECIFIC AREA
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE FOR ME TO.
HAVE IT JUST TO ME THAT THE
RIGHT AS A NEW IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY THAT THERE MAY BE
LANGUAGE ASPECTS ISSUES ON WITH
THE ACCESS TO LICENSURE MAY BE
SINCE YOU'RE SEEING CERTAIN
TRENDS WITH RESPECT TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING MAYBE SEEING
GARNISHES A WAGES WHICH THEFT
WHAT ARE THOSE TYPE OF THINGS
THAT I THINK MIGHT
DISPROPORTIONATELY HURT THESE
RECENT IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
GIVEN THE TYPE OF CHALLENGES
THAT EXIST. WAIT IF ANY IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY NEED TO BE
THAT THAT THERE IS ONE BUT ONE
THAT MIGHT STAND OUT. THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE THAT I I'M
EXPERIENCING IS THE EDUCATIONAL.
THE LANGUAGE BARRIER AT THE
EDUCATIONAL COMPONENT AS THEY
NEED TO TREAT BEFORE THEY
TRANSITION INTO THE STATE'S OUR
ARENA OF OBTAINING THAT LICENSE
IS THE DIFFICULTY PRIOR TO THAT
LICENSING STATUS BECAUSE ONCE
THEY REACH US. ON TO FIND OUT
THEIR LICENSING MEANS WE CATER
TO THE MEN AND THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE THAT THEY DESIRE SO
ANY AREA THAT THE EXPERIENCE IS
BY. NOT STATE CITIZEN OF OURS
STATE RESIDENT ISSUE IT'S THAT
NEWLY RESIDENTS ISSUE WITH
WHATEVER'S EXISTING BEYOND
STATE INSIDE THAT INDUSTRY
THREE TO JUST LIKE LANGUAGE
ACCESS IS WHAT YOU WOULD THAT
LANGUAGE BARRIERS. IN SUMMARY
LANGUAGE LANGUAGE IT IS THE
GREATEST CHALLENGE FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE IN IN THE NEVADA
JURISDICTION BECAUSE WE DO NOT
OFFER THE PROGRAMS. I AM I AM
UNAWARE OF A SCHOOL THAT OFFERS
THE PROGRAMS IN LANGUAGES OTHER
THAN ENGLISH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'RE GONNA GO TO MISTER
SHADE FOR JUST A MOMENT LET ME
ASK A FINAL QUESTION TO YOU
BOTH. THE UNLICENSED SIDE OF
THIS INDUSTRY. DO YOU YOU COULD
EITHER YOU SPEAK TO WHAT YOU
KNOW OF THE ON LICENSE. FOLKS
DOING THIS IN THE NEVADA OR
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT MR A
HIGGINBOTHAM YOU WANNA START
THEIR TEACH YOU KNOW. WHO WHO'S
PRACTICING IN YOUR STATE THAT
DOESN'T HAVE A LICENSE. WE HAVE
TEAMS TO MONITOR SOCIAL
NETWORKS AND IF THERE ARE
ADVERTISEMENTS AND THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS NOT LICENSED.
THEN WE SEND THEM A NAME.
CITATION PRETTY MUCH AND
THEY'LL HAVE TO PAY THAT
CITATION. IF THEY DON'T
COOPERATE BY REMOVING THAT THEN
WE GET LOCAL AUTHORITIES
INVOLVED WITH THAT. OR WE
FOUND. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE
BEEN LAS VEGAS IS FULL OF H.
AWAY SO. HM WAYS ARE A GREAT
PLACE FOR US TO SAY HEY THERE'S
A NON AUTHORIZED BUSINESS
OPERATING IN YOU GET A
COMMUNITY. THAT TYPE OF ISSUE.
HELPS US. TACKLE AND LICENSE
ACTIVITY AND YOU HAVE A SENSE
OF WHETHER IT'S BEEN GOING UP
GOING DOWN. AND NUMBERS TO
FOLKS WHO ARE PRACTICING.
WITHOUT A LICENSE AND YOUR
STAGE OF ANY IN ANY SENSE OF
THAT. NO THEY'RE GETTING.
THEY'RE GETTING SMARTER WITH
OTHER ADVERTISING ON SOCIAL
NETWORKS SO. OKAY AND WHAT
ABOUT DATA AND OTHER STATES
NATIONALLY I AM OBVIOUSLY AND
LICENSE TO A PRACTICES AN ISSUE
IN EVERY STATE I WOULD CLARIFY
TO SAY THAT AND LICENSE DOESN'T
ALWAYS MEAN AN EDUCATED. AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW IN YOUR OWN
NUMBERS CERTAINLY IN LARGE
NUMBER PEOPLE DON'T PASS EXAMS
EVERY YEAR DOESN'T MEAN THEY-DON'T PRACTICE IT JUST MEANS
THEY DON'T RETURN TO TRY TO
PASS THE EXAM THE SECOND TIME
SO IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE
EQUIVALENT OF NOT BEING
EDUCATED THEY MAY JUST NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO. PASSED THE EXAM
REQUIRED AND THAT COULD BE A
LANGUAGE BARRIER OR SOME OTHER
ISSUE BUT IT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THE NUMBER ONE WAY THAT
UNLICENSED WORKERS ARE
DISCOVERED IS THROUGH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING INVESTIGATIONS SO
THIS ISN'T INDUSTRY WITH. I'M
NOT A SURPRISE ANY OF YOU HAVE
TO SAY THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
LARGE NUMBER OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS THE SENATE STRING AND
IT'S VERY HARD FOR REGULATORS
ON INSPECTORS TO DETERMINE
WHERE THAT'S OCCURRING AND I
OFTENTIMES STATES FIND THAT OUT
THROUGH. FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS
FBI THAT TYPE OF THING IF
THROUGH HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INVESTIGATIONS. YOU A DEBT
PROVIDED SOME TESTIMONY EARLIER
ABOUT INJURIES THAT HAVE COME
FROM THESE TYPES OF FIVE
PRACTICES THAT HAVE GONE BAD IS
THERE ANY BREAKDOWN OF THOSE
TYPES OF INJURIES BASED ON
LICENSE ON LICENSE FOR DONE. SO
I GET THAT QUESTION ALL THE
TIME PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW WHAT
IS DONE YOU KNOW WHAT IS THAT
ANSWER SOMEBODY UNLESS THE
PROBLEM WITH ALL OF THIS IS
THAT IF YOU ARE NOT LICENSE
IT'S A MATTER OF THE BOARD
ANYMORE SO TO TRY TO. CORRAL
THOSE NUMBERS AT TIMES YOU'VE
ENTERED SOME ANOTHER. SITUATION
IT'S NO LONGER. SO IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT. TO CALL THOSE
NUMBERS. NOT GONNA HAVE THAT.
ON THE BOTTOM TEAR AND
CERTAINLY NOT THE ON LICENSE
RECURSOS NUMBERS ARE REALLY
HARD TO COME BY. AND WITH THAT
WANT YOU TO STAND BY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
SEE WE GO BACK TO MISTER SHADE
FOR WE HAVE AN AUDIO CONNECTION
THAT WERE. CAN BRING ON UP HERE
.
THE ON THE LINE NOW
. SAYS
SENATOR GLAZER AND ENSURE LOW
THE BACK HERE IN THE AND
CALIFORNIA CAN YOU CAN HEAR US.
YES I CAN HEAR IT IT'S VERY
FAINT BUT- I CAN HEAR A LITTLE
BIT OKAY LET YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
MOUTH CLOSE TO THE RECEIVER WE
CAN HEAR YOU VERY WELL AND
AGAIN SORRY FOR THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. AND WE WELCOME
YOU TO BE TO BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY AGAIN. SO. WHERE I
LEFT OFF BEFORE OUR TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WAS TALKING ABOUT
ARE OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING
CONSORTIUM THAT THE COUNCIL
STATE GOVERNMENTS THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE
LEGISLATURES IN THE NATIONAL
GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION HAS
CONVENE OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS OF THAT INITIATIVE IS
FUNDED BY A GRANT FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. AND THERE
SIXTEEN STATES THAT HAVE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN THE CONSORTIUM
AND WITH THE BROAD GOALS OF
HELPING THE STATE. TO ENSURE
THAT EXISTING AND NEW
REQUIREMENTS ARE OVERLY BROAD
OR BURDENS RESTRICTIVE. AND
THAT THEY DON'T CREATE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO LABOR
MARKET ENTRY AND IN SECOND TO
IMPROVE THE PORTABILITY AND
RECIPROCITY PROVISIONS FOR
OCCUPATIONS TO HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS MOVED THEIR
LICENSE ACROSS STATE LINES SO
IF WE MOVE TO THE NEXT SLIDE WE
CAN SEE ON THE MAP. THE PURPLE
STATES ARE THERE IS AND
ORIGINAL APPLICATION PROCESS OR
ELEVEN STATES WERE ADMITTED TO
JOIN THE CONSORTIUM AND THEN
FIVE MORE WERE ADDED AT. A
LATER DATE DUE TO SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO. SHE IS
SHE HAS BEEN HEAVILY INVOLVED
IN THIS WORK FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS HELPING THE STATE. TACKLE
THIS COMPLEX ISSUE AND SO I
HAVE JUST PULLED OUT FIVE HIGH
LEVEL SCHEMES OR SOME TRENDS
THAT WE'VE SEEN AMONG THE STATE
AND THEN STAYED OUTSIDE OF THE
CONSORTIUM AS WELL THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH. SO WE GO TO
THE NEXT SLIDE THE FOR THE
FIRST TRAINED I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT IS TARGETED RFORM FOR
SPECIFIC POPULATION. AND SO
FOOD WE GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE WE
CAN SEE THE FIRST POPULATION
THAT WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF STATES
REALLY PUT EMPHASIS ON. HIS
MILITARY SPOUSES. SO THE MAIN.
THE MAIN ISSUE HERE IS MILITARY
SPOUSES DUE TO THEIR SPOUSES
DEPLOYMENT OFTEN MOVE VERY
FREQUENTLY. A LOT OF TIMES TO
DIFFERENT BASES IN DIFFERENT
STATES WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THEM
TO. GET RE LICENSED UPON MOVING
TO THE NEW STATE SO SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN STATE
ADOPT TO REMOVE THESE BARRIERS
FOR MILITARY SPOUSES LICENSURE
BY ENDORSEMENT WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY A STATE ISSUING A
NEW PERMANENT LICENSE WITHOUT
ANY KIND OF FURTHER TRAINING OR
EXAMS. IF THE APPLICATION IS
MOVING FROM A STATE WITH
SIMILAR STANDARDS. TEMPORARY
LICENSURE JUST ALLOWS A SPOUSE
TO PRACTICE FOR A SPECIFIED
PERIOD OF TIME WITHOUT FILLING
ANY NEW REQUIREMENTS FINISHES
FIRST THAT PERIOD OF TIME. AND
AN EXPEDITED LICENSORS IS THE
FAST PASS STORE FAST LANE WEARS
THEM THE STATE BOARD PROCESSING
THE APPLICATION WILL PRIORITIZE
THE SPOUSES. APPLICATION IN
OFTEN. I PASSING A LOT OF THE
STEPS REQUIRED FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. AND THEN LASTLY
EXEMPTION THE FOUR STATES
ARIZONA FLORIDA ISLAND UTAH HAS
JUST SAID MILITARY SPOUSES DO
NOT NEED TO GO TO THE LICENSING
PROCESS IN THE NEW STATE THEIR
PREVIOUS OLD STATES LICENSE
WILL BE RECOGNIZED. IN THE NEW
STATE SO HERE'S ON A FLORIDA
AND IOWA YOU DO NOT HAVE TO GET
RE LICENSED IF YOU ARE AN
MILITARY ABOUT. THEY'LL
RECOGNIZE THAT OLD LICENSE SO
WE GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE WE CAN
SEE SOME STATS ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S SO SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
SPOUSES IN CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
A COUPLE PROVISIONS THIS IS
BASED ON THE UNIVERSITY OF
MINNESOTA STUDY WHO DID A FIFTY
STATE AUDIT OF LICENSING BOARDS
AND HOW THEY PROCESS MILITARY
SPOUSE APPLICATIONS. SO WE CAN
SEE A COUPLE BILLS HERE THAT
ARE PERMITTED TO MILITARY
SPOUSES THAT REQUIRE EXPEDITED
LICNSURE IN THE IN. AB NE
EIGHTY SIX WHICH I FORGOT THE
DAY BUT AS IT WAS TWENTY
FOURTEEN REQUIRED TEMPORARY
LICENSURE. SO THOSE TWO THINGS
ARE IN PLACE FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES. THE UNIVERSITY
MINNESOTA'S STUDY THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY WORD TO EXPAND THE
THOSE TWO BILLS AND ALLOW AND
AN ENDORSEMENT PROCESS AS WELL
FOR SPOUSES. AND IT'S ALSO
ENCOURAGE BOARD STAFF TO
IMPROVE THEIR UNDERSTANDING AND
APPLICATION OF THESE BILLS I
GUESS THERE IS A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE LAW IN WHAT IS
BEING PRACTICED BY THE STATE
BOARD. THAT'S MILITARY SPOUSES
WE GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE ANOTHER
SPECIFIC POPULATION OF FOLKS
THAT WE SEEN A LOT OF MOVEMENT.
IN THIS AREA OF REGULATION
REFORM IS WITH PEOPLE WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS. SO THE MAIN
BARRIER HERE IS A LOT OF
LICENSING STATUTES CONTAIN
LANGUAGE THAT ARE SOMEONE WITH
A CRIMINAL RECORD FROM GETTING
A STATE LICENSE SO IT MIGHT
HAVE A FELONY BLANKET BAN OR
FOR CERTAIN MISDEMEANORS IT
WILL SAY THE BOARD EITHER SHALL
OR MAY. DENY LICENSURE FOR
THESE FOLKS SO HERE'S SOME SOME
DIFFERENT POLICY OPTIONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN STATES PURSUE SO
LIMITATIONS ON TYPE OF
CONVICTIONS CONSIDERED THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY JUST. LIMITING THE
CONVICTIONS THAT A BOARD MAY
CONSIDER NGUYEN DENYING FOR
LICENSURE SO MAYBE JUST THEY
WOULD JUST DENY FOR VIOLENT
CRIMES OR OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT SO IT'S- NARROWING THE
SCOPE. AND NOT BEING AS AS
BROAD AN ALL ENCOMPASSING.
LIMITATION BASED ON TIME SINCE
CONVICTION SO THAT SET THE TIME
PERIOD USUALLY SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FIVE AND TEN YEARS THAT
TELLS THE LICENSING BOARD IF
THE CRIME OCCURRED. BEYOND THIS
SET AMOUNT OF TIME THEN THE
BOARD CAN NOT CONSIDER IT AND
THEIR THEIR- APPLICATION WERE
YOU. DIRECT RELATIONSHIP
REQUIREMENTS THAT ESSENTIALLY
IS MANDATING THAT THE BOARD
PROOF THAT THERE IS A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CONVICTION IN THE LICENSE THAT
YOUR YOU THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
APPLYING FOR INDIVIDUALIZED
CONSIDERATION THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY. ESTABLISHING A
METHODOLOGY OR CRITERIA FOR
BOARD TO THAT THEY'RE THEY HAVE
TO CONSIDER WHEN THEY'RE
REVIEWING A SOMEONE WITH A
CRIMINAL RECORD THEIR LICENSE
APPLICATION AND AGAIN ALL OF
THESE ARE ESSENTIALLY JUST
TRYING TO NARROW THE SCOPE TO
THE INDIVIDUAL AND NOT MAKE
BROAD BLANKET STATEMENTS THAT
WOULD PROHIBIT CERTAIN PEOPLE
WHO WHO MAY HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
REHABILITATED AND PAID THEIR
DEBT TO SOCIETY AND WE WOULD
MAKE A GREAT LICENSE THE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP THE BOARD
BECOME MORE NARROW IN TAILORED
IN SPECIFIC WITH THE REVIEWS SO
THAT. EVERYONE IS NOT BARRED
FROM LICENSURE. PRELIMINARY
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION
THAT'S ONE WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
STATES PURSUE KNOW THAT AS THE
EXAMPLE THAT I SAY HERE. AND
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY THE
INDIVIDUAL WITH THE RECORD CAN
PETITION THE BOARD AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS TO SEE IF THERE'S A
CONVICTION THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
HIM FROM RECEIVING A LICENSE
SO. IT HELPS THEM ON THE FRONT
END SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THIS IN GET ALL THIS
TRAINING AND DO ALL THIS
EXPERIENCE ONLY AT THE VERYEND
OF THE PROCESS TO FIND OUT.
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN DENIED SO
IT TELLS AND AT AT THE VERY
ONSET AT THE FRONT OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WHETHER OR
NOT THEY HAVE A CONVICTION THAT
WOULD PROHIBIT THEM FROM
ACHIEVING THE LICENSE. AND THEN
WRITTEN NOTICE OF THE NILE THIS
REQUIRES THE BOARD TO SAY YOU
KNOW PRECISELY WHY THEY DENIED
AND NOT NOT JUST TELL SOMEONE
THAT THEY WERE DENIED IN USE
FAKE LANGUAGE BUT AS SAY
EXACTLY PRECISELY. WHAT THE
REASONING FOR THAT WAS. FIVE
FOODS SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
POLICY OPTIONS THAT WE SEEN.
FOR PRE PEOPLE WITH CRIMINAL
RECORDS. ON THE NEXT SLIDE OUR
OUR LAST KIND OF TARGET
POPULATION THAT WE'VE SEEN A
LOT OF STATES FOCUS ON. IS
IMMIGRANTS IN FOREIGN TRAINED
APPLICANTS IN IN ONE THING I
HIGHLIGHT HERE FROM UTAH. IS
THE USE OF COMPETENCY BASED
ASSESSMENT SO THE MAIN THE MAIN
BEER HERE FOR IMMIGRANTS IS A
LOT OF TIMES LICENSING BOARDS
DO NOT. RECOGNIZE TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE THAT SOMEONE HAS
RECEIVED FROM THE OUTSIDE OF
THE COUNTRY SO THE CLASSIC
EXAMPLE. OF THE YOU KNOW THE
PHYSICIAN FROM INDIA WHO.
DRIVING A CAB OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. WE WANT TO HELP THESE
FOLKS TO YOU. GET THEIR THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND THEIR TRAINING
RECOGNIZED FOR A STATE LICENSE
HERE IN AMERICA SO UTAH HAS
SAID TO THESE COMPETENCY BASED
ASSESSMENT THAT WE'RE GONNA TRY
TO MOVE AWAY FROM THESE TIME
BASED. TIME SENSITIVE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS YOU KNOW A
THOUSAND HOURS OR THREE YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE OR- SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AIM JUST PROVED TO US
THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY DO THE
TRADE THAT YOU'RE- THAT YOU'RE
APPLYING. FOR THE FOR THE
LICENSE SO H. B. TWO TWO SIX IS
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWING UTAH'S.%
LICENSING DEPARTMENT TO UTILIZE
COMPETENCY BASED ASSESSMENTS
RATHER THAN THESE THESE TIME
BASED REQUIREMENTS WHICH WOULD
REALLY HELP IMMIGRANTS BE ABLE
TO PROVE THAT HE'S COMPETENT IN
HIS AREA OFTRADE WITHOUT
HAVING TO. GO THROUGH THE FULL
LICENSURE PROCESS OVER AGAIN.
ON THE NEXT SLIDE WE CAN SEE
SOME OTHER STRATEGIES THAT
WE'VE SEEN STATES PURSUE I
THINK THE MOST POPULAR ONE JUST
DEVELOPING AN IMMIGRANT
LICENSING GUIDE THAT SECOND ONE
IT'S REALLY LOW COST AND REALLY
EASY. AND IS ESSENTIALLY JUST
MAPPING OUT YOU KNOW WHAT DOES
IT TAKE AS AN IMMIGRANT FOR YOU
TO RECEIVE A STATE LICENSE AND
YOU'RE GIVEN FIELD. A LOT OF
TIMES ESPECIALLY IF ENGLISH AS
A SECOND LANGUAGE JUST THE
WHOLE LICENSING PROCESS IN THE
STRUCTURE IN THE STATE IS SO
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE THAT THEY
JUST GIVE UP ON THE FRONT AND-
AND DON'T PURSUE THAT SO IF
THERE IF THERE IS LITERATURE
AVAILABLE THAT WOULD. CLEARLY
MAP OUT THE STEPS THAT IT TAKES
TO RECEIVE A LICENSE IN THEIR
GIVEN FIELD THAT WOULD GO A
LONG WAY. AND ALSO YEAH
ESTABLISHING BRIDGE PROGRAMS IN
INVESTING IN. ENGLISH CLASSES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT. SO THAT'S
REALLY THAT'S THE FIRST TREND
THAT WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF STATES
PURSUE A THESE TARGET REFORMS
FOR. SPECIFIC OCCUPY A SPECIFIC
POPULATIONS OF FOLKS SO SPOUSES
PEOPLE CRIMINAL RECORDS AND
IMMIGRANTS. WE GO TO THE NEXT
SLIDE THE SECOND TRENDS THAT I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT IS THIS
CONCEPT OF UNIVERSAL LICENSE
RECOGNITION SO WE MOVED TO THE
NEXT SIDE WE CAN SEE THERE'S
THREE STATES THAT CURRENTLY.
HAVE UNIVERSAL RECOGNITION AND
WHAT I MEAN BY UNIVERSAL
RECOGNITION IS THEY WILL
UNIVERSALLY EXCEPT IN OUT OF
STATE. APPLE CAN THEY WILL
RECOGNIZE THAT OUT OF STATE
LICENSE SEE IF CERTAIN CRITERIA
ARE MET. AND I WILL KNOW SO OUT
OF THESE THREE PENNSYLVANIA
MONTANA IN ARIZONA. ARIZONA IS
THE ONLY ONE THAT DOESN'T HAVE
A CLAUSE THAT REQUIRES THE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS TO BE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR SO THAT'S
KEY BECAUSE IN MONTANA AND IN
PENNSYLVANIA THEY HAVE THIS
UNIVERSAL RECOGNITION THE LAW
IN PLACE BUT IT STILL SAYS THAT
YOUR OLD STATES REQUIREMENTS
NEED TO BE. SIMILAR TO OURS AND
LICENSING BOARD. WILL REVIEW TO
ENSURE THAT THE REQUIREMENT TO
SIMILAR. ZONA DOES NOT SAY THAT
THEY THEY DO NOT CARE WHAT THE
OLD STATES REQUIREMENTS WERE
ALL THAT THEY CARE ABOUT IS
THAT YOU'VE ESTABLISHED ARIZONA
RESIDENCY AND PASS AN EXAM SO
WE GO. TO THE NEXT SLIDE WE CAN
SEE. WHAT ARE THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR UNIVERSAL RECOGNITION UNDER
THE ARIZONA MODEL SO ALL ALL
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PROVEN IS THAT
YOU ARE IN ARIZONA RESIDENTS.
YOU'VE BEEN LICENSE FOR AT
LEAST A YEAR IN YOUR OLD STATE.
YOU COMPLETED ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE ORIGINAL
STATE. AND IN ANY ERA ZONA
SPECIFIC EXAMS BEYOND THE
LICENSING EXAMS SO THIS IS NOT
TALKING ABOUT IF YOU'RE
APPLYING TO BE A PLUMBER THIS
IS NOT THE PLUMBING SAND. BUT
ADDITIONAL EXAMS LIKE
JURISPRUDENCE EXAMS OR IN AT
THE EXAM OR ARE AN EXAM ON A
ARIZONA SPECIFIC LOSS OF NOT A
LICENSEE SAM BUT- AND OTHER
ADDITIONAL EXAM WITH THAT. NO
DISQUALIFYING CRIMINAL HISTORY
IN AND PAY YOUR FEES SO THAT
THAT'S ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IN
ARIZONA TO QUALIFY. AS AN OUT
OF STATE APPLICATION TO RECEIVE
AN ARIZONA LICENSE THAT WE'VE
SEEN A LOT OF STATES THAT ARE
REALLY INTERESTED IN THIS
CONCEPT. I WILL NOTE. THAT IT'S
MOSTLY LEGISLATORS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN THIS AND PEOPLE
IN THE REGULATORY COMMUNITY ARE
NOT AS KEEN ON THIS IDEA. AND
ALSO NOTE THAT THIS. STRUCTURE
THIS UNIVERSAL LICENSE
STRUCTURE DOES NOT INTERFERE
WITH. EXISTING RECIPROCITY
AGREEMENT SO IF. THERE IS AN
INTERSTATE COMPACT IN THE
PROFESSION OR AN EXISTING
RECIPROCITY AGREEMENT THE
UNIVERSAL RECOGNITION DOES NOT
AFFECT THAT IN ANY WAY THIS IS
JUST FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T
ALREADY HAVE SOME SORT OF. A
RECIPROCITY SYSTEM IN PLACE.
THAT IS THE SECOND TRADE I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT UNIVERSAL
RECOGNITION THERE'S A LOT OF
MEDIA COVERAGE ON THIS GOVERNOR
DO YOU SEE AN ARIZONA. DROVE UP
TO THE SIGNING OF THE BILL AND
THE YOUTH AND THE U. HAUL TO
SYMBOLIZING WE WANT PEOPLE TO
MOVE TO ARIZONA. IN IN SO WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE ALL THESE AT
THE STATE LICENSEES THAT ARE
APPLYING IN ARIZONA. FOR THE
SURGERY AND I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT IS. THE STATE A STAB
MACHINE A SUNRISE AND SUNSET
PROCESS. IN SO IT THIS IS
SOMETHING I KNOW THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS CURRENTLY TASKED
WITH IS HIS SON SETTING. THE
SUNSET REVIEW FOR THE
COSMETOLOGY BEAUTY LICENSING
BOARDS SO TO YOU ON THE THIS
SUNRISE AND IS A REVIEW BEFORE
THE BREAK IT BEFORE CREATE ANY
REGULATION SUNSET. IS IT STILL
NEEDED AFTER THE REGULATION HAS
BEEN HAS BEEN CREATED SO I DO
NOT BELIEVE CALIFORNIA HAS
SUNRISE PROVISION FOR LICENSING
BOARDS BUT- OBVIOUSLY THERE IS
A SUNSET PROVISION ALREADY IN
PLACE. SO WE GO TO THE NEXT
SLIDE WE CAN SEE SOME CRITERIA
THAT STATES HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT FOR WINTER SUN RISE AND NEW
BOARD TO INTRODUCE A NEW.
REGULATION AND I PULLED THESE
FROM VERMONT FROM THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE THEY HAVE A
REALLY ROBUST SUNRISE AND
SUNSET. STRUCTURE IN THAT STATE
AND SO THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS
THAT THEY ASK WHEN THEY SUNRISE
A NEW BOARD SO IS THERE ON
REGULATED PRACTICE. THAT CAN
CLEARLY HARM ENDANGER THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE WELL
AND OF. OR WELFARE OF THE
PUBLIC AND IT'S NOT IT'S THE
HARM IS RECOGNIZABLE IT'S NOT
REMOTE IT'S NOT SPECULATIVE.
AND THAT THE PUBLIC CAN BE
REASONABLY BENEFITTED OF
ASSURANCE OF INITIAL AND
CONTINUING PROFESSIONAL ABILITY
AND THERE'S NO OTHER LESS
RESTRICTIVE MEANS BY WHICH THE
PUBLIC CAN BE PROTECTED SO
SOMETHING LIKE A CERTIFICATION.
OR REGISTRATION OR MAYBE
INSURANCE OR BONDING OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. ON THE
NEXT SLIDE WE CAN SEE SUNSET
CRITERIA SO THIS IS WHAT FOR
MINE THE QUESTIONS THEY ASK
WHEN SUN SETTING ABOARD. IT IS
STILL IN THE INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC IN FILLING IN FOR
LEGISLATIVE INTENT THEY THINK
ABOUT COST SCOPE OF REGULATIONS
SO DOES THE AMOUNT OF TRAINING
AND EXPERIENCE THAT WE'RE
REQUIRING IT IS ACT HE COOL TO
THE POTENTIAL HARM. ARE THE
REQUIREMENTS CONSISTENT WITH
PUBLIC INTEREST IS. AT THE SIDE
PUBLIC OPINION EFFECTIVENESS
AND COMPLAIN SO ALL THESE
THINGS ARE THINGS THAT THEY'RE
CONSIDERING WHEN THEY SUNSET
ABOARD. AND SO WE MOVED TO THE
NEXT SIDE WE CAN SEE SEVERAL
STATES THAT HAS INTRODUCED
THESE SUNSET PROCESSES JUST
THIS PAST LEGISLATIVE SESSION
WE SEEN THE BRASS CAM LOUISIANA
HEIAU. AND THEY HAVE COMMITTED
TO EXAMINING A FRACTION OF
THEIR LICENSING BOARDS EACH
EACH YEAR IN NEBRASKA'S EXAMPLE
TO ONE FIFTH EVERY FIVE YEARS
SO ALL THE BOARDS GET EXAMINED
OCE EVERY FIVE YEARS. THEY
MUST PROVE THAT THERE IS
PRESENT SIGNIFICANT
SUBSTANTIATED HARM AND THEY'RE
ALSO REQUIRED TO CONSIDERED THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE MEANS OF
REGULATIONS. FIRST BEFORE THEY
MOVE ON TO FULL LICENSURE. AND
IT'S INTERESTING THE OHIO BILL
ACTUALLY. NOTE THAT THE BOARDS
WILL EXPIRE EVERY SIX YEARS
UNLESS THEY'RE EXPLICITLY
RENEWED BY LAWMAKERS SO IT'S
REQUIRING LEGISLATORS TO TAKE
THAT ACTIVE STEP TO RENEW THE
BOARD AND IF THEY DON'T IT WILL
AUTOMATICALLY EXPIRE. FIVE SO
THAT IS THE THIRD AND I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE MOVE TO THE NEXT
SLIDE THE FORCE CHANGING
REGULATORY STRUCTURE. SO WHAT
AM I TALKING ABOUT HERE. EACH
STAGE STRUCTURES THEIR
LICENSING BOARDS VERY
DIFFERENTLY SOME STATES. LIKE
CALIFORNIA HAVE A CENTRALIZED
SYSTEM WHERE THERE'S AND IN
UMBRELLA AGENCY THAT HOUSES ALL
OF THEIR BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. OTHER STATES THE
BOARDS ARE COMPLETELY
INDEPENDENT AND THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN RULE MAKING AUTHORITY THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN FEE STRUCTURES
SEPARATE FROM OTHER LICENSING
BOARDS THEIR THEIR
INDEPENDENCE. AN AUTONOMOUS.
AND SO WE'VE SEEN A IN THE WAKE
OF NORTH CAROLINA DENTAL CASE
THAT WENT TO THE SUPREME COURT.
THAT ESTABLISHED THAT LICENSING
BOARDS MUST HAVE ACTIVE STATE
SUPERVISION FROM A NEUTRAL
STATE ENTITY ARE WE SEEING A
LOT OF STATE TO MOVE AWAY FROM
THIS AUTONOMOUS STRUCTURE IN A
INTO A CENTRALIZED STRUCTURE SO
WE SEEN. IT IT IT ALL STEMS
FROM THIS THIS NEED TO
ESTABLISH ACTED STAYS
SUPERVISION SO LICENSING BOARDS
ARE AFRAID THAT IF THEY REMAIN
AUTONOMOUS AND INDEPENDENT.
THAT AN ACTION THAT THEY TAKE
AGAINST THE LICENSEE MIGHT BE
CONSIDERED A VIOLATION OF THE
ANTI TRUST LAW AND THEY COULD
BE PERSONALLY HELD LIABLE. THAT
THAT BIG RULING FROM THAT NORTH
CAROLINA CASES WELL IS THAT THE
BOARD THE BOARD MEMBERS AND OF
CAN INDIVIDUALLY HE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ACTIONS TAKEN
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD AND- WE
SEE A LOT OF STATE. TRYING TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES BY
ESTABLISHING THIS ACTIVE STATE.
SUPERVISION A WITH WOULD BE.
ALSO INTERESTED IN CENTRALIZING
JUST FOR IT MINISTRY TO
PURPOSES SO GROUP BEING
AGENCIES TOGETHER AND BROAD
FUNCTIONAL AREAS CREATING A
CONNIE'S OF SCALE AND
ESTABLISHING JUST A FEW
DEPARTMENTS RATHER THAN ALL OF
THESE INDEPENDENT BOARDS WHO
ARE KIND OF YOU KNOW OUT ON
THEIR OWN. SO IF WE MOVE TO THE
NEXT SLIDE WE CAN SEE THIS
COMES FROM THE COUNCIL OF
LICENSURE ENFORCEMENT AND
REGULATION CLEAR IT CREATED
THIS MODEL STRUCTURE OF HOW
STATE BOARDS ARE SET UP SO WE
CAN SEE MODEL A AT THE TOP.
COMPLETELY AUTONOMOUS AND IN
MODEL HE AT THE VERY BOTTOM
WHERE THERE'S A CENTRAL AGENCY
THAT HAS COMPLETE AUTHORITY AND
BOARDS ARE ARE YOU ADVISORY
ONLY SO STATES ARE FALLING
SOMEWHERE IT'S NOT AS RIGID AS
THEIR INDEPENDENCE OR DEPENDENT
BUT THERE'S KIND OF THIS
SPECTRUM. THAT THAT BOARDS ARE
FALLING UNDER. IN THEIR THEIR
REGULATORY STRUCTURE. UNTIL WE
MOVED TO THE NEXT SLIDE WE CAN
SEE SOME SPECIFIC. REFORMS THAT
STATES HAVE DONE THE PAST YEARS
SO COMBINING SIMILAR
OCCUPATIONS UNDER AN UMBRELLA
BOARD SO THAT WOULD BE LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE TAKING THE COSMETOLOGY
BOARD. IN THE BARBERING BOARD
AT THOSE RISKS SEPARATING
CREATING ONE SINGLE UMBRELLA
BOARD SO PURSUING THAT IDEAL
CENTRALIZATION THERE. KENTUCKY
IT IS IN THERE ATTEMPTING TO
CENTRALIZE ALL OF THEIR
LICENSING BOARD. UNDERNEATH ONE
CABINET. MISSISSIPPI IN
OKLAHOMA AND ESTABLISHED
COMMISSIONS THAT ARE ARE
REGULARLY REVIEWING BOARD SO
THAT THEY HAD THAT THAT ACTIVE
STATE SUPERVISION. THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT. FROM THE NORTH
CAROLINA DENTAL CASE. BUT THAT
IS THE FOURTH TREND IF WE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT SLIDE. FIFTH AND
FINAL TREND THAT I WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT THAT STATES ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN IS THE INTERSTATE
COMPACT SO THE ISSUE HERE IT
GOES BACK TO THE MOBILITY ISSUE
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT WITH
UNIVERSAL RECOGNITION HOW DO WE
HELP. PRACTITIONERS MOVE ACROSS
STATE LINES MORE SEAMLESSLY
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO THROUGH
THE FULL LICENSURE PROCESS OVER
AGAIN. SO WHAT IS AN INTERSTATE
COMPACT ESSENTIALLY IT IS AN
AGREEMENT A FORMAL CONTRACT
BETWEEN STATE. THAT THEY ENTER
INTO THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND IT'S BINDING IT
BINDS STATES TOGETHER INTO AN
AGREEMENT TO SAY THAT THERE
JOINT LEAD GOING TO DO
SOMETHING TOGETHER SO WE'VE
SEEN. A LOT OF STATES PURSUE
THESE FOR OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING RECIPROCITY. A IN THE
COUNCIL STATE GOVERNMENT HAS A
PARTICULAR EXPERTISE AN
INTERSTATE COMPACT BECAUSE WE
ARE ACTUALLY HOME TO THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR INTERSTATE
COMPACT HERE AT CSG IT'S A
POLICY PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE.
WHERE WE ASSIST PROFESSIONS IN
STATE IN THE DEVELOPMENT IN THE
MAINTENANCE OF INTERSTATE
COMPACTS ONCE THEY'RE AS STAB
LIST. SO WE'RE THE ONLY
INFORMATION CLEARINGHOUSE AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER.
ON INTERSTATE CONTACTS IN THE
WHOLE COUNTRY. BUT IF WE MOVE
TO THE NEXT SLIDE WE CAN SEE.
HERE OUR THE ACTIVE INTERSTATE
COMPACT ON THE LEFT SIDE SO
THERE ARE CONTACTS IN PLACE FOR
NURSING FOR MEDICINE FOR
POSITIONS EMS COMPACT IS FOR
EMS PROFESSIONALS. PHYSICAL
THERAPY SIDE PACKED IS FOR
PSYCHOLOGY AND SPECIFICALLY
DEALS WITH TELL US PSYCHOLOGY.
AND THEN IT BANS PRACTICE
NURSING SO WE HAVE SEEN A LARGE
NUMBER OF PROFESSIONS EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN DEVELOPING THESE
YOU CAN SEE ON THE RIGHT SIDE
THESE ARE THE PROFESSIONS THAT
WE ARE CURRENTLY. IN THE
PROCESS WITH THE SPEECH THERAPY
AND AUDIOLOGY COMPACT IS
FINISHED AND FINALIZED AND WILL
BE AVAILABLE FOR PASSAGE AND
LEGISLATORS AND TWENTY TWENTY.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE DENTAL
COMMUNITY ON DENTAL HYGIENE
POSITION SAYS AND T. A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL. LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL. COUNSELORS AND
LASTLY TEACHERS SO. WE SEE THIS
BE A VERY EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR
ACHIEVING RECIPROCITY AMONG
STATES YOU CAN SEE THE NURSE
LICENSE OR CONTACT AS THIRTY
FOUR STATES THAT ARE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THAT CONTACT SO IF
YOU ARE IF YOU LIVE IN A
COMPACT STATE. ESSENTIALLY ACTS
AS A IS SIMILAR TO A DRIVER'S
LICENSE WHERE YOU CAN PRACTICE
IN ANY OTHER STATE THAT
PARTICIPATES IN THE COMPACT
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO THROUGH
AND- GO THROUGH THE ROOF THE
RELATIONSHIP PROCESS SO IT'S
SEAMLESS YOU CAN JUST CROSS
STATE LINES AND- CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
THROUGH. THAT BURDENSOME
PROCESS OF RE APPLYING TO THE
BOARD AND IN WAITING FOR YOUR
APPLICATION BE ACCEPTED AND
PAYING THE THIS ON THESE UNITS
TO GO ACROSS STATE LINES LIKE.
YOU WOULD IF YOU WERE DRIVING A
CAR ACROSS STATE LINES. AND WE
SEE AN INTEREST IN THESE
DISTRICTS BLOATING OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS WE EXPECT THE
NURSE LICENSURE CONTACT TO
CONTINUE TO GAIN MOMENTUM AND
WILL PROBABLY. BE ABOVE FORTY
STATE HERE WITH HER VERY SOON.
SO THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
HAS OFFICIALLY ENDORSED
INTERSTATE COMPACT IS REALLY
THE GOLD STANDARD FOR
ESTABLISHING LICENSE
RECIPROCITY. THESE LIKE
PIECEMEAL RECIPROCITY
AGREEMENTS ARE TEMPORARY
SOLUTIONS BUT INTERSTATE
COMPACT OR SEEN AS REALLY THE
MAIN IS THAT THE GOLD STANDARD
FOR ACHIEVING LICENSE
RECIPROCITY. SO IF WE MOVE TO
THE NEXT SLIDE I APOLOGIZE I'M
NOT SURE HOW WELL THIS TEXT
WILL SHOW UP BUT YOU CAN SEE
THE PARTICIPATING STATES AND
ALL THE CONTACT. IN THE WHITE
STATE ARE STATES THAT DO NOT
PRACTICE IN ANY OF THE
CONTACTING SEE CALIFORNIA HAS
NOT ENTERED INTO ANY OF THESE
AGREEMENTS. AND THE DARKER
STATES ARE THE ONES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN MORE SO THERE
ARE THERE'S NO STATES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN ALL OF THEM SO
IT'S A VARIETY OF. KIND OF
RANGES THE SPECTRUM FOR HOW
STATES ARE UTILIZING THESE SO.
EACH INTERSTATE COMPACT IS
REALLY DIFFERENT THIS IS NOT
MODEL LEGISLATION THIS IS NOT
YOU KNOW A PURSE PRESCRIPTIVE
PROCESS BUT- WE REALLY TRY TO
BE COLLABORATIVE AS
COLLABORATIVE AS POSSIBLE AND
BRINGING PEOPLE ROM ALL OVER
THE PROFESSION. AND POLICY
MAKERS FROM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. TOGETHER TO JOINTLY.
DALGLISH THE THESE COMPACT SO
THAT NO ONE STATE CAN SAY YOU
KNOW I WASN'T A PART OF HELPING
DRAFT THIS WE REALLY LIKE TO
BRING A DIVERSE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER WHEN
MAKING THESE SO. WE GO TO THE
NEXT SLIDE THAT IS ALL THAT I
HAVE I'M NOT SURE. IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS BUT I'D BE HAPPY
TO TAKE THEM NOW OR IF WE MOVE
ONE MORE SLIDE MY CONTACT
INFORMATION. AND I'LL JUST NOTE
THAT U. R. L. THE BOTTOM
LICENSING DOT C. S. T. AT WORK
THAT'S A WEBSITE THAT HOUSES
ALL OF OUR OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING WORK THAT WE PRODUCE
LOTS OF REPORTS. DIFFERENT
POLICY BRIEF. THERE IS A
DATABASE ON THERE THAT HAS
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL
FIFTY STATE. SO WE TOOK THIRTY
FOUR DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS AND
MAPPED OUT THE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL FIFTY
STATES SO YOU COULD DO A
COMPARISON. TO SEE HOW
CALIFORNIA RANGE VERSUS
NEIGHBORING STATES OR THE WHOLE
REGION OVER THE WHOLE COUNTRY
WHATEVER YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
SO THAT'S A VERY USEFUL TOOL AS
WELL. SO I WILL STOP THERE AND
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT I COULD POTENTIALLY ANSWER
NOT SURE HOW WELL BE ABLE TO
HEAR THEM BUT- DRY. SO MATTER
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AB VERY
INFORMATIVE I THINK YOU
STIMULATED A LOT OF FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS A FEW OF WHICH I MASS
TODAY BUT YEARS CERTAINLY A
GREAT RESOURCE FOR A WHAT IS
HAPPENING AROUND THE COUNTRY IN
THIS IN THIS AREA YOU KNOW I'M
TRYING TO WRESTLE WITH THAT THE
SLIDE THAT YOU SHOWED AT THE
END WHERE THESE INTERSTATE
COMPACTS SHOWS CALIFORNIA HAS
A- HAS REALLY HAD. NOT ENTERED
INTO ANY OF THEM. AND THE YOU
KNOW THE AD EVERYBODY WILL HAVE
A REASON FOR THAT BUT
CERTAINLY. AT THE HEART. OF THE
OF THAT IS A CONCERN THAT THE
STANDARDS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPLIED IN THOSE PLACES. FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY. ARE ADEQUATE
FOR US. AND THIS IS THAT THIS
IS A CHALLENGE WE WE'VE SENT
OUT A LITTLE BIT TIME OR
EARLIER IN THIS HEARING AND
ROUGH YOU COULD LISTEN AND HER
COULD HEAR AND- TALKING ABOUT
THE DIFFERENT STANDARDS AROUND
THE COUNTRY FOR TRAINING AND
EDUCATION. DO YOU HAVE ANY
BROAD OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THAT
ISSUE OF HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
THEN HOUSE OF MANY STATES ARE
INTERPRETING THIS IMPORTANT
QUESTION SO DIFFERENTLY. SURE
SO I THINK I GOT THE GIST OF
YOUR QUESTION SO IF YOU NOTICE
ON. ON THE SLIDE THAT THAT
SHOWS WHICH PROFESSIONS HAVE
HAVE ESTABLISHED THESE
INTERSTATE COMPACTS. ALL OF
THEM ARE IN AND HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS AND THERE'S A
REASON FOR THAT AND CONTACTS
REALLY THRIVE ON UNIFORMITY SO
UNIFORMITY OF REQUIREMENTS
MAINLY. SO LET IT FROM OUR.
WHEN WE DEVELOP THESE CONTACTS
WE ESTABLISH A UNIVERSAL
STANDARD FOR PRACTICE SO YOU'RE
NOT SAYING THAT YOU ARE
ACCEPTING ARIZONA STANDARDS BUT
THE COMPACT ITSELF IS CREATING
A NEW STANDARD THAT STATES ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO HEAR TO IN
SOME OF THE STATES WILL HAVE TO
RAISE THE BAR TO ENTER INTO THE
COMPACT. IN THE STATE'S MIGHT
HAVE TO LOWER THEIR BAR TO
ENTER INTO THE CONTACT BUT
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS WE'VE
SEEN ARE FAIRLY UNIFORM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND THEIR LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS OF WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A NURSE IN CALIFORNIA IS
TYPICALLY WHAT IT TAKES TO BE A
NURSE IN IN MOST OTHER STATES
SO THAT YOU KNOW BACHELOR'S
DEGREE PASSING THE AND COLLECT.
AND IN HAVING SOME SORT OF
FELLOWSHIP OR ASSISTANTSHIP SO
IN THE SAME FOR THE MEDICAL
LICENSE OR COMPACT IN PHYSICAL
THERAPY THESE ARE ALL
PROFESSIONS WHERE STANDARD TO
PRACTICE IS PRETTY UNIFORM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THE
DIFFERENCES ARE. ARE MORE
MENIAL I WILL NOTE SO I HAVE.
TEACHERS UNDER. CONTACTS AND
DEVELOPMENT STAGE THAT'S ONE
PROFESSION IS THAT THAT IS
CERTAINLY AN OUT LIAR ON THIS
LIST THE ALL THE OTHER
PROFESSIONS ARE ARE HEALTH
CARE. BUT TEACHERS THAT THAT'LL
BE. A DIFFICULT CONTACT TO
ESTABLISH BECAUSE THE STANDARDS
ARE ARE SO VASTLY DIFFERENT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND BECAUSE
SO MANY THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT TRACKS TO BECOMING A
TEACHER I TO BE VERY HARD TO
ESTABLISH ONE SINGLE STANDARD.
THAT STATES WILL IT HERE TOO
WHEN THEY ENTER INTO THE
COMPACT SO THAT'S HOW I WOULD
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION IS
THAT COMPAQ'S REALLY THRIVE ON
UNIFORMITY AND THAT'S WHY.
THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS THAT
HAVE PURSUED THESE IS BECAUSE-
THEY HAVE RELATIVE UNIFORMITY.
AND THEIR LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND SO MATT IS IT NAIVE OF ME
TO RAISE THE QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER THE COMPLEXITY THAT
GOES INTO BEING A NURSE. IS
HIGHER OR LOWER THAN THE
COMPLEXITY THAT GOES INTO BEING
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF SOMEONE'S
NAILS. SORRY I MISSED THE LAST
PART OF THAT QUESTION LINE AYE
AYE AYE YEAH I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WITHIN THE
COSMETOLOGY. AND BARBERING
AREAS THAT WHY WE'RE FAILING TO
COME UP WITH A REASONABLE
STANDARDS IS IT. AND I GUESS IT
WAS A- A YOU KNOW SOMEONE
SUGGEST THAT BEING A NURSE IS
SOMEWHAT MORE COMPLEX. IN
TRAINING AND EDUCATION AND
SAFETY THAN THAN ONE MIGHT.
NEEDED TO TAKE CARE OF
SOMEONE'S NAILS. YOUR HAIR ANY
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THAT. SURE
SO YEAH I MEAN SO FOR NURSING I
MEAN IT'S- THE STANDARD ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IS REALLY FOUR YEAR
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND PASSING
THE AND COLLECTS THE NURSING
EXAM SO THAT I THINK THAT'S A
PRETTY YOU KNOW A FOUR YEAR
DEGREE WHAT IS. I WOULD SAY THE
HIGHER BAR THAN JUST A AS A SET
NUMBER OF TRAINING HOURS IN IN
BEAUTY SCHOOL. I DON'T BELIEVE
FOR BARBERING IN COSMETOLOGY
THERE'S ANY KIND OF EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS OTHER THAN THE
ACTUAL NUMBER OF HOURS IN
BEAUTY SCHOOL THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE REQUIRED YOU. TO LOG SO
A IN THAT I WILL SAY WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROFESSIONS THAT
HAVE UNIFORMITY. THIS IS
CERTAINLY THE BEAUTY
PROFESSIONS IN COSMETOLOGY IS
CERTAINLY A INDUSTRY THAT DOES
NOT HAVE UNIFORMITY THE GATE
AND YOU CAN TELL BY THE
DATABASE THAT I CITED THAT HAS
ALL HE LICENSING REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS CITY STATE. THE VARIANCE
BETWEEN THE LOW END OF THE
NUMBER OF HOURS IN THE HIGH END
IS EXTREMELY HIGH I KNOW SOME
STATES REQUIRE TWO THOUSAND
HOURS AND THEN THERE'S OTHER
STATES THAT. REQUIRE LESS THAN
A THOUSAND SO THERE REALLY IS
NOT I DON'T THINK STATES HAVE
COME TO ANY KIND OF A CONSENSUS
WHEN IT COMES TO. APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF ENTRY LEVEL
REQUIREMENTS FOR THESE BEAUTY
PROFESSIONS AND MATT DO YOU
HAVE A VIEW OF AS WHY THAT IS
SO WHAT WHAT WHY WHY ARE WE
HAVING SUCH STRUGGLES THERE TO
FIND UNIFORMITY. AND REASONABLE
STANDARDS. SURE I THINK THAT
ONE MAJOR FACTOR IS. THAT THE
BEAUTY THE STATE BOARD AND THE
THAT BEAUTY SCHOOLS HAVE AN
INCENTIVE THAT TO KEEP THE
HOURS HIGHER SO THE LONGER.
YOU'RE IN SCHOOL THE MORE MONEY
THAT THAT BEAUTY SCHOOL MAKE
THEY HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO KEEP
THE HOURS AS HIGH AS POSSIBLE.
AND I THINK REGULATORS AND
POLICY MAKERS ARE KIND OF. YOU
KNOW COMING TO THEIR SENSES A
DATING THING DO YOU KNOW DO WE
REALLY NEED TO BE REQUIRING TWO
THOUSAND HOURS OR BOARD THIS
PROFESSION WHEN MAY BE YOU KNOW
A MORE REASONABLE AND NOW WOULD
BE TWELVE HUNDRED OR SOMETHING
THAT SOMEWHERE MORE IN THE
MIDDLE. BUT THE BEAUTY SCHOOLS
THAT ARE YOU KNOW PROFITING OFF
OF THESE APPLICANTS. HAVE
INCENTIVE TO KEEP THE NUMBER AS
HIGH AS POSSIBLE SO I THINK
THAT'S A BIG REASON IS. THE
BEAUTY SCHOOLS WANT. TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN SCHOOL AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE. AND ARE THERE ANY
PLACES THAT YOU THINK WE SHOULD
LOOK TO HAVE A MORE OBJECTIVE
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT WHAT REALLY
IS REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS
THAT WE ALL WANT. I WOULD I
WOULD JUST POINT YOU TO THE-
THAT DATABASE OF REQUIREMENTS
THAT I MENTIONED I THINK YOU
KNOW IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF HOURS. THAT OTHER
STATES HAVE DONE AND MAYBE.
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
RATIONALE FOR WHY WOULD YOU
KNOW STAY ONLY OFF ONLY A
REQUIRE THOUSAND AND MAYBE
THINK ABOUT MOVING MORE TOWARDS
THAT THAT LOW AND WE'VE WE'VE
DEFINITELY SEEN. DATE. BAKER
LEE AND THIS INDUSTRY OF THE
BEAUTY PROFESSIONS. THE
REGULATING MORE INSTEAD OF AT
RAMPING UP THE REGULATION SO I
DON'T I DON'T SEE ANY STATE
ADDING ON MORE HOURS I ONLY SEE
STATE REMOVING THE NUMBER OF
HOURS THAT THEY REQUIRE SETTING
NATIONALLY THERE'S IS KIND OF A
TREND. TO KIND OF LOOSENED THE
REQUIREMENTS A LITTLE BIT AND
THIS THIS AREA. BUT YEAH I
WOULD JUST I WOULD LOOK AT THAT
THE DATABASE AND LOOK AT THE
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS STATES AND
PICK SOMETHING IN THE MIDDLE
YOU KNOW MAYBE YOU DON'T WANT
TO BE THE STATE WITH THE LOWEST
REQUIREMENTS BUT- IF YOU'RE ON
THE HIGHER AND- MAYBE THINK
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHY ARE ALL
THESE OTHER STATES. I REQUIRING
SO MANY LAST. THING CALIFORNIA
ONE MORE FOLLOW QUESTION FOR ME
AND THEN OTHERS ON THE PANEL
MAY HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS MATT.
SO THE I HEAR WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT TRYING TO FIND THAT
MIDDLE GROUND BUT MY CHALLENGE
ON THE HOURS ISSUE. IS THAT IT
ALL SEEMS VERY ARBITRARY I'D
LIKE TO FOCUS ON. THE MERITS
THE SUBJECT MATTER THE
COMPLEXITY THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS THAT WE THINK
ARE REASONABLE. RATHER THAN
THIS ARBITRARY NATURE OF OURS I
MEAN I KNOW I TALK ABOUT IT A
LOT THIS HEARING SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS SEEMS. TO ME TO
BE EXCESSIVE WHEN IT TAKES.
EIGHT HUNDRED PLUS HOURS TO BE
A POLICE OFFICER AND YOU CAN
LOOK AT IT. YOU KNOW YOU CAN
EVEN LOOK AT LOOK YOU CAN LOOK
AT IN RELATION TO OTHER.
PRACTICES AND THEIR EDUCATION
TRAINING BUT- AT THE END OF THE
DAY. IT SHOULD JUST BE ABOUT AN
ARBITRARY NUMBER IT REALLY
SHOULD BE ABOUT WHAT ARE WHAT
ARE THE OUTCOMES ARE TRYING TO
SEE. WHAT ARE THE COMPETENCIES
WE WANT THEM TO ACHIEVE. SO
HEALTH AND SAFETY IS PROTECTED
SO. I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
ABOUT. ALSO IN THE MAIL.
THERE'S A LOW THERE'S A HOT.
HELP THERE ARE WHAT. IS THIS. I
KNOW THE OUT OF. THAT WE THINK.
ARE REASONABLE. AND THEN AND
THEN TO GO FROM. BUT LET ME SEE
I CHAIR LOW ANY FOR FATHER
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. NOT MISTER
FALL FALL QUESTION BUT SIMILAR
TO CHECK ON SOME OF THOSE
COMMENTS OF SHARING
OBSERVATIONS TO. WE LOOK AT THE
BUREAU OF LABOR AND THE REPORTS
THAT THE MEAN INCOME. OF FOR
MANY THESE INDIVIDUALS IS
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND A
COMMENSURATE WITH THAT TYPE OF
TRAINING. AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
SO I THINK IT'S OUR OUR
OBLIGATION TO TAKE A LOOK AT
SEEING WHAT. BEARERS THEY MIGHT
BE TO HELP THEM BE SUCCESSFUL
SETTING THEM UP FOR SUCCESS.
PARTICULAR. GIVEN THE COST OF
LIVING ALSO. IN IN THE STATE.
ABSOLUTELY I I'D BE HAPPY TO
JOIN AND I. SINCERELY APOLOGIZE
FOR ANY INCONVENIENCE AND I
HOPE ITWAS STILL. BENEFICIAL
FOR THE COMMITTEE IT WAS THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET ME UP
BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
I JUST WANNA GIVE LESLIE IN
ADAM AN OPPORTUNITY TO BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING TO FOLLOW MATT AND
OUR ORIGINAL SCHEDULE BUT I
WANT TO SEE IT TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REACT IN A THEIR
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD WITH
HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY
AND- IN CLOSING ON THIS.
MICROPHONE. DOES THE TWO THINGS
THAT I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
WHEN HE'S HOT TALKED ABOUT THE
CONSISTENCY AND HEALTH CARE
PART OF THE DIFFERENCE AND
HEALTH CARE POPULATIONS IS THAT
WHEN YOU GRADUATE FROM A
PROGRAM WHETHER IT'S IN NURSING
OR MEDICINE OR ANYTHING IT'S
ALWAYS AN ACCREDITED PROGRAM
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WE HAVE WITH BEEN CONSISTENT IN
COSMETOLOGY IS THAT IS SO MANY
PROGRAMS THAT DON'T FALL INTO
THAT ACCREDITED STATURE SAYS A
STATUTE SO WHEN YOU MIX THOSE
TWO THINGS OF NON ACCREDITED
SCHOOLS AN ACCREDITED. SCHOOLS
IN THE FALL OFF THAT GRAPHIC
THAT HE HAD. FIND OUT. WHAT
TYPE OF EDUCATION GETTING BE MY
ONE COMMENT. Q. ADAM ANYTHING
YOU WANT TO SAY IN REGARD TO
MATS TESTIMONY. MR SHAFER SAID
A- A LOT OF STUFF THAT I AGREE
WITH IN THAT WE AGREE WITH
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TARTED THIS
PROJECT SO WE CAN IDENTIFY THE
RISK CAN CHANGE A DIALOGUE.
THAT IS OCCURRING BECAUSE IT
SEEMS LIKE THE DIALOGUE IS VERY
KERN IS ABOUT HOURS. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHERE THE ORIGINAL
OUR REQUIREMENT IF EVER CAME UP
THAT'S WHY. THIS TYPE OF
DOCUMENT YOU KNOW WE'RE WORKING
ON IDENTIFYING THE RISK. IS A
GOOD FOUNDATIONAL POINT OF US.
REESTABLISHING WHERE THOSE
HOURS CAME OUT IN THE FIRST
PLACE. HE ALSO RAISED THAT I
MEAN FOR US WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND OBJECTIVE INFORMATION SO
WE MAKE GOOD CHOICES. AND HE HE
RAISE THE QUESTION THAT THERE
IS A SELF PROTECTION INTEREST
IN DETERMINING THE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS. THAT WAS PRETTY
PRETTY POINTS AS AN EIGHT AND
I'M NOT AGREEING OR DISAGREEING
WITH IT EXCEPT THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR WORK HERE. TRYING
TO ASSESS THIS AND CARP THE
PATHWAY GOING FORWARD. WE WANT
TO MAKE US MORE CHOICES AND WE
WANT TO BRING IN EXPERTS AND
THERE ARE FOLKS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THIS FIELD FOR A
LONG TIME THAT ARE VERY SOME
SMARTER THAN ME FOR SURE. AND
CERTAINLY WHEN HE GETS INTO
THE- THE AT THAT THE MEDIA OF
THE EDUCATION PROGRAM YOU KNOW
I WANT TO HEAR FROM SMARTER
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT REALLY IS
REQUIRED AND WHY AND HAVE IT BE
JUSTIFIED IN. BUT I WANT TO
HAVE I WANT TO HAVE. THAT
INFORMATION I CAN TRUST. AND
THAT ISN'T BASED ON A SELF
INTEREST. AND THAT'S PART OF
OUR CHALLENGE GOING FORWARD I
KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS WE CERTAINLY HAVE
GREAT STAFF EXPERTISE HERE THAT
WE CAN RELY UPON. SO WITH THAT
I'M GONNA GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
LIST AND ANYONE ELSE HAS
ANYTHING TO ADD OKAY WELL THANK
YOU TO BOTH OF YOU. FOR
TRAVELING HERE LESLIE BOSTIAN
ADAM HIGGINBOTHAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR SHARING YOUR
EXPERTISE WITH US VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. SO IF OUR FOLKS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THEIR
VIEW AND OUR PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION WE HAVE A MICROPHONE.
ON THE SIDE OF THE ROOM. THERE
THAT FOLKS INCOME AND SHARE
THEIR THOUGHTS. WE HAVE JUST A
COUPLE MINUTES LEFT ANYBODY
WANT TO PROVIDE ANY THOUGHTS IN
OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY SECTION.
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY YOURSELF
FOR THE RECORD IF YOU WISH.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST AFTERNOON
FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF THE
PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA. JUST A COUPLE OF
POINTS. THERE SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
LICENSING BY THE STATE BOARD OF
BARRING COSMETOLOGY IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S OVER 2% OF
EVERY ADULT IN CALIFORNIA. TWO
OUT OF A HUNDRED. THROW A
BOWLING BALL IN A ROOM FULL OF
PEOPLE YOU'LL IT TO STE TWO
PEOPLE LICENSE BY THIS BOARD.
SO THE QUESTION OF BARRIERS TO
ENTRY. I'M NOT SURE WHO'S
BAKING THAT QUESTION BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME IT'S A SOLUTION
LOOKING FOR A PROBLEM. MISS
RUSTY ACSI SERVED WITH ME IN A
NUMBER OF INDUSTRY FOLKS ON A
RECENT STATE BOARD CONVENE TASK
FORCE ON THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
OUR PROGRAM. AND BY CONSENSUS
WE AGREED THAT THE SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS OFFERED IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE MIDDLE GROUND
OF ALL FIFTY STATES WE WENT
THROUGH ALL OF THE CURRICULUM
AND DECIDED IT WAS APPROPRIATE.
HOWEVER MY ASSOCIATION WANTS TO
EMBRACE COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION. WE THINK WE SHOULD
THE STATE SHOULD OFFER IT AS AN
OPTION. DON'T THROW THE BABY
OUT WITH THE BATHWATER OUR
INDUSTRY HAS ALREADY HAD TO
ABSORB A LOT OF MAJOR CHANGES
RECENTLY. BUT MAYBE REQUIRE
FOUR HUNDRED HOURS OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY THEORETICAL
INSTRUCTION AND THEN ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO CERTIFY THE
TECHNIQUE COMPETENCIES. SO THAT
YOU BASS HAVE A BASE AMOUNT OF
HOURS AND THEN A CERTIFICATION
PROCESS I THINK THERE'S LOTS OF
WAYS WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THAT. WE
ALSO PROPOSE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING EXTERNSHIP RIGHT NOW
YOU HAVE TO GET 60% OF THOSE
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS BEFORE
YOU CAN QUALIFY TO WORK IN THE
SALON AS AN EXTRA AS AN UNPAID
EXTRA. WE WOULD LIKE TO REDUCE
THOSE HOURS GET KIDS INTO SALON
SOONER AND ALLOW THEM TO BE
PAID. WERE ALLOWING THE PROCESS
TO BE PAID AFTER ONLY RECEIVING
THIRTY NINE HOURS OF
INSTRUCTION. AND THEN THEY GO
THROUGH A TWO YEAR PROCESS OF
BEING EARNING WHILE THEY'RE
LEARNING SO WE THINK EXTERNSHIP
SHOULD BE DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED. IN TERMS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAMS I
BELIEVE THERE'S ONLY SIX
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAMS
TEACHING COSMETOLOGY IN THE
ENTIRE STATE BUDGET TWELVE NOW
OKAY SO THERE'S ONLY TWELVE AND
PART OF THAT REASON IS
COMMITTEE COLLEGES VALUE TO BUY
TWO TRANSFERS THEY'RE LOOKING
OUT FOR YOUR DEGREES AS A
PRIORITY WE CERTAINLY WOULD.
EMBRACE MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS BEING OFFERED. BUT
GOOD LUCK DEALING WITH EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
THEIR THEIR OWN FIVE TIMES.
RECIPROCITY MOST OF THE
PRESENTATION AT THE END WAS
ABOUT STATE COMPACTS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX WE SPONSORED A
BILL WITH LIZ FIGUEROA SENATOR
FIGUEROA TAX TO CREATE
LICENSURE BY ENDORSEMENT SO
IT'S A MOOTPOINT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IF YOU WANT TO MOVE FROM NEW
YORK TO CALIFORNIA THE SHOW
THAT YOU'VE WORKED THREE OF THE
LAST FIVE YEARS WITH A LICENSE
IN NEW YORK YOU PAY A FIFTY
DOLLAR APPLICATION FEE AND YOU
GET A LICENSE TOMORROW. SO A
LOT OF THAT PRESENTATION WAS
FAIRLY IGNORANT OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
ACCOMPLISHED DO YOU REALIZE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE BARBERING
PROGRAMS HAPPENING IN OUR STATE
PRISONS. AND THAT ANY CONVICT
CAN APPEAL TO THE STATE BOARD
IN ADVANCE OF THEIR EDUCATION
TO FIND OUT WHETHER THEIR
CRIMINAL OFFENSE WILL
DISQUALIFY THEM FROM LICENSE.
STARBOARD FREE DECADES HAS
PUSHED THE ENVELOPE IN
EMBRACING PEOPLE THAT HAVE
CRIMINAL BACKGROUNDS. TO BE
ABLE TO COME AND BE LICENSED IN
OUR INDUSTRY. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW YOU MENTION THE THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR A YEAR SALARY.
I HATE TO ADMIT IT. WE HAVE A
HUGE UNDER REPORTING PROBLEM IN
OUR INDUSTRY IN ALL CASH
BUSINESSES THAT'S TYPICAL IT'S
VERY TYPICAL IN OUR INDUSTRY
AND THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM
WHEN YOU START GETTING INTO
DEBT TO RATIO INCOME EARNING
RATIOS. WE HAVE SUCH A HUGE
PROBLEM OF UNDER REPORTING. THE
IRS LABOR STATISTICS BOARD HAVE
NO CLUE HOW MUCH WE ACTUALLY
EARN I CAN SHOULD PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION THAT OUR STATE
BOARD PRESIDENT HAS COMPILED
FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
IT'S OVERWHELMING WHAT A UNDER
REPORTING PHENOMENON AND
PROBLEMS THE HOUSE IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND JUST ONE FINAL
COMMENT TO CHAIRMAN GLAZER. AS
AN ATTORNEY I CAN TELL YOU YOU
CANNOT TAKE THE BAR EXAM UNLESS
YOU'VE GONE TO A STATE
ACCREDITED SCHOOL. FOUR YOU'VE
WORKED UNDER A JUDGE FOR FOUR
YEARS AND PAID QUARTERLY FEES
TO THE STATE BOARD FOR FOUR
YEARS. SO JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT ONE CLARIFICATION. GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER JONES ANY UP
OR ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. IF YOU LINE UP
BEHIND THE MIKE SO I KNOW HOW
MANY REMAIN THAT WOULD BE GOOD
IF HE'S A LOT OUT OF TIME.
THURSDAY AND DECIDE ON THE
AISLE HIGH. GOOD YOUR NAME AND
PLEASE AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME IS
JAMIE SHOT BACK AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE AUDIENCE
KNOW ME WELL BECAUSE OVER THE
LAST TWELVE YEARS I'VE ATTENDED
MORE THAN FIFTY FIVE STATE
BOARD MEETINGS AT MY OWN
EXPENSE. I'M A LICENSE MEDICARE
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND I
OWN AN EMPLOYEE BASED NAIL
SALON IN CARMEL CALIFORNIA. I
DID EARN A FOUR YEAR DEGREE AND
SHORTLY THERE AFTER ACTUALLY
PAID MY WAY THROUGH GRADUATE
SCHOOL DOING NAILS. TO EARN A
PHD IN EDUCATION WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION AND LANGUAGE AND
LITERACY SO I COULD SPEND HOURS
TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION IN OUR
INDUSTRY BUT I'D RATHER FOCUS
ON A COUPLE OTHER THINGS
INSTEAD. I TEACH MORE CLASSES
AT MORE BEAUTY SHOWS THAN ANY
OTHER DEAL PRO IN OUR INDUSTRY.
AND I'M COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT
I TEACH AT SHOWS IN THE STATES
THAT HAVE THE LARGEST LICENSEE
POPULATION SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT
NEW YORK FLORIDA TEXAS ILLINOIS
OHIO SO I INTERACT WITH THESE
PEOPLE ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
LESLIE INTERACTS IN A DIFFERENT
WAY BECAUSE SHE'S TRAVELING ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY AND DEALING
DIRECTLY WITH THE LEGISLATORS.
AND THE REGULATORS I'M DEALING
WITH THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
I'M DEALING WITH THE LICENSEES
IN THE SALON OWNERS ALL OVER.
AND I WILL SAY THAT. NOTHING TO
THIS POINT THAT ANY STATE. HAS
LEGISLATIVE WORTH CONSIDERING
LEGISLATING IS NEARLY AS
IMPORTANT OR IMPACTFUL AS WHAT
CALIFORNIA COULD AND SHOULD DO
THAT IS THE LEVEL OF INFLUENCE
AND POWER THAT YOU HAVE OVER
THIS INDUSTRY. AND I JUST WANT
TO ADD A FEW THINGS HERE BUT
REFER TO MY NOTES AND I'M OLD
DEL SECTOR CLASSES. BUT I WANT
TO SAY. THAT SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF BOTH PERSONALLY ND
PROFESSIONALLY. I'D RATHER BE
ALONE THAN IN BAD COMPANY. AND
I THINK THIS IS A TIME WHERE WE
DEFINITELY HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE
OUR LEADERSHIP. AND WE HAVE
THAT POWER TO DO THAT. AS A
MANICURIST I KNOW A LOT OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS COME BACK
TO MALES. AND I AM READY AND
PREPARED FOR THE SCRUTINY THAT
I FEEL THAT WE DESERVE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE IF WE
CANNOT. JUSTIFY HOW WE DO
THINGS. AND WHY WE DO THE
THINGS THAT WE DO. THEN WE
SHOULD BE CHALLENGED.
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO COULD
DEFINITELY USE IMPROVEMENT BUT
I WILL SAY TO THIS POINT THAT.
CHRISTY UNDERWOOD AND HER STAFF
HAVE WORKED DILIGENTLY OVER THE
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE BOARD WHICH IS BEEN OVER
TWELVE. TO MEET LEGISLATIVE
MANDATES. OVER THE YEARS AND
PERHAPS THE LEGISLATURE WAS AND
ALWAYS ASKING FOR THE RIGHT
THINGS. AND O HERE WE ARE. SO
GOING FORWARD LET ME JUST POINT
OUT THAT. WE CAN ATTACK THIS
LOTS OF DIFFERENT ANGLES AS A
CONSUMER WE TELL CONSUMERS. TO
DO THEIR RESEARCH. BY LICENSURE
THE BREEZE SYSTEM BUT WHAT'S
THE POINT THE TECHNOLOGY WHEN
ESTABLISHMENT OWNERS AND
LICENSEES CAN MARKET THEMSELVES
AND ADVERTISE WITH FAKE NAMES
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT THAT YOU
IS A LICENSEE ACTUALLY USE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ADVERTISEMENT SO
I WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE
WORTHWHILE TO REQUIRE US IS
LICENSEES ESTABLISHMENT OWNERS
TO ADVERTISE WITH OUR LICENSE
NUMBERS SO THAT CONSUMERS CAN
DO THEIR DUE DILIGENCE AND LOOK
US UP AND MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
HOLD. A VALID LICENSE FROM
BORDER BARBERING COSMETOLOGY.
WE NEED TO UPDATE OUR LICENSING
CATEGORIES THIS GOES ALONG WITH
THE COMP ASIAN ABOUT OUR
REQUIREMENTS WE SHOULD HAVE A
HERE ONLY LICENSE WE SHOULD
HAVE LICENSES FOR PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO WAX ONLY OR WHO WANT TO
MAKE UP ONLY. SO THEY CAN GET
INTO THE INDUSTRY FASTER THAT
WILL REDUCE THE BARRIER TO
ENTRY. AND THEN LASTLY AS WERE
MENTIONED THAT. WE DO NOT HAVE
A CLEARLY DEFINED SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR ANYTHING THAT WE
DO WHERE IS THE BOUNDARY
BETWEEN. MEDICAL AND BEAUTY
pPODIATRY. AND NAILS. WE DON'T
HAVE IT THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE ALL
THIS FUNNY STUFF HAPPENING WE
HAVE PEOPLE DOING INGROWN
TOENAIL WORK. WITH PEOPLE
GETTING INFECTIONS I SERVE AS
AN EXPERT WITNESS NOT ONLY FOR
THE STATE BOARD BUT I ACTUALLY
DO TAKE ON CASES THAT INVOLVE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SUING.
THEY'RE SUING THE
ESTABLISHMENTS THEY'RE TRYING
TO GET COMPENSATION. NOW ALL
THESE THINGS RUN THROUGH THE
STATE BOARD IN FACT MOST OF THE
LAWYERS I TALKED TO HAVE NO
INTEREST IN HAVING THEIR CLIENT
REPORT THEIR INJURY THE STATE
BOARD BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WHERE
THE MONEY IS MONEY IS IN THE
INSURANCE COMPANY. SO FOR ALL
THE INJURIES THAT WE FIND OUT
ABOUT BECAUSE THEY ARE POSTED
OR LESLIE'S COLLECTING THESE
PHOTOGRAPHS. THIS IS THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG. SO I WOULD ASK
THAT. WE BE A PART OF THIS
PROCESS AGAIN I WELCOME THE
SCRUTINY. I WOULD WANT TO US TO
BE ABLE TO JUSTIFY OUR
EXISTENCE AND TO EARN YOUR
TRUST AS LICENSEES THAT WE'RE
HERE TO FOLLOW THE LAW. BUT WE
ALSO ASK THAT YOU. REGULATORS
JUDICIOUSLY SO THAT WERE ABLE
TO COMPETE N A VERY
COMPETITIVE INDUSTRY SO THAT WE
CAN DO OUR BEST. IT'S UP TO US
TO ALSO PROTECT OUR CLIENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY YES SIR NEXT UP.
CENTER GLAZER AND SIMPLY MEN
LOW AND COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME SPEAK MY NAME IS
PETER WEST RECKON THE
PROFESSOR. AT RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. I GET SOMEONE
TO TAKE THE FOR THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM TODAY. BUT I'VE
BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND THE- WITH
ALL THE INDUSTRY IN TWENTY
YEARS IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR THE
DUCATION OF BEEN DEPARTMENT
CHAIR AND DIRECTOR OF
COSMETOLOGY RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE NOW FOR THE PAST
SIXTEEN YEARS I WAS ALSO
PRESENT AT THE MEETING THAT
MISTER JOHNSON SPEAKING OF OR
THE CURRICULUM. COMMITTEE GOT
TOGETHER AND LOOKED AT THE
CURRICULUM NOT ONCE DID WE
DISCUSS HOURS FOR OUR BENEFIT
AS YOU KNOW IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR I GET PAID EITHER WAY
DOESN'T MATTER TO ME. BUT WE
LOOK AT THE CURRICULUM AND
STILL LEARNING OUTCOMES WHAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE GOING TO
PERCEIVE WHAT THEY SHOULD LEARN
AT THE END OF THE DAY. I HAVE
TO KIND OF REMEMBER THAT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CURRICULUM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TEACHING STUDENTS A CHANGE IN
BEHAVIOR WHICH CAUSES THE
COGNITIVE DOMAIN. AS CYCLE
MOTOR SKILLS SAID DOMAIN AND
EFFECTIVE DOMAIN WHICH CAUSES A
CHANGE OF BEHAVIOR NOT SIMPLY
REMEMBERING FACTS BUT WE WANT
THEM TO CHANGE BEHAVIOR SO THAT
WHEN THEY GET EMPLOYED. THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE ON. WORKING
IN RISK FREE AND INDUSTRY SO
THEY DON'T HAVE THESE PROBLEMS
LATER DOWN HE ROAD WAS SITE
AND FIND IN ISSUES. SO THERE'S
THE DESIRE THERE'S THE AND PUT
THERE'S THE ASSIMILATION AND
THE OTHER PART IS THE
REPETITION THAT STUDENTS NEED
TO DO. TO BECOME EFFECTIVE IN
INDUSTRY. SO WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE HOURS SCOPE OR THE HOURS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ACTUALLY OUR PROGRAM IN OUR C.
C. IS ACTUALLY. SIXTEEN HUNDRED
FIFTY HOURS WE HAVE STUDENTS TO
STICK AROUND FOR TWO THOUSAND
HOURS. BECAUSE THEY WANT THAT
SECURITY BEFORE THEY GET
LICENSE. WE JUST HAD A REMEDIAL
CLASS HAD FORTY STUDENTS ATTEND
REMEDIAL NOT BECAUSE THEY
NEEDED TO ARE REQUIRED TO BUT
THEY WANT TO COME TO. THE
COLLEGE AND GET FURTHER
TREATMENT. FURTHER EDUCATION SO
WE CALL REMEDIAL COURSE AND THE
BIGGEST THING THAT I SEE IN THE
REMEDIAL COURSES IS THAT.
PEOPLE ARE COMING INTO THE
INDUSTRY WITH NOT A CHANGE IN
BEHAVIOR THEY COME WITH FACTS
TO PASS THE TEST. AND COGNITIVE
SKILLS SETS TO OUR CYCLE MORE
SCHOOL SAYS TO PASS THE TEST
AND THEN FROM THERE ON THE
DON'T LEARN. WE NEED A CHANGE
IN BEHAVIOR FOR THE STUDENTS
AND THOSE ARE DETERMINED BY THE
STUDENT LEARNING OUTCOMES SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE OUR
STRUCTURE ONCE AGAIN WE
GOVERNMENT IS THE COGNITIVE
SKILL SET. THERE'S A PSYCH
MOTOR TO MAIN SKILL SET. AND
THEN THE REPETITION WHICH IS
THE EFFECTIVE DOMAIN TO GIVE
THE STUDENTS VALUE FOR WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WE GRADUATE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED STUDENTS YEAR I
THINK WE'RE DOING PRETTY GOOD
AT OUR PUBLIC. COMMITTEE
COLLEGE OF WHERE WE'RE AT AND
RIVERSIDE. AND I NOT SURE I
THROUGHOUT TWELVE BUT WE KEEP
INCREASING. BARSTOW COMMITTEE
COLLEGES OPEN UP THE
COSMETOLOGY PROGRAM WE JUST
OPEN UP IN AS STAKES PROGRAM.
WHEN THE BIG BENEFITS THAT WE
HAD THIS LAST. THREE YEARS AGO
AND WE'RE ON OUR FOURTH YEAR
FUNDING CYCLE NOW IS STRONG
WORK FORCE. AMY GAVE US A LOT
OF THAT DOLLARS AND STATE
DOLLARS TO MATCH THAT SO I'M
WITH YOU CENTER GLAZER WHO
COMMITTEE COLLEGES DO NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB IT'S CLEAR TECH
EDUCATION. AND WE COULD USE THE
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JUST COMING TO THE END HERE YES
MA'AM WELCOME TO SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS OF I SPOKE BRIEFLY
LAST TIME MY NAME IS WENDY
COCHRAN I'M A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN I'M THE FOUNDER OF
CALIFORNIA. ASCETIC LIFE A
STATIC ALLIANCE AND WE ARE
REGISTERED WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS A TRADE AGENCY
AND FOR EDUCATION. I REPRESENT
OVER FIVE THOUSAND LICENSED
ESTHETICIANS IN MY GROUPS AND
CONTINUING EDUCATION IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR US I
BELIEVE THAT WHEN WE ARE
DISCUSSING THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE VALUE OF THE
PRIVATIZED SCHOOLS VERSUS THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL EDUCATION THAT THEY ARE
RECEIVING IS. MORE ON TARGET
WITH STAYING WITHIN SCOPE OF
PRACTICE THEY TEND TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE RELIABLE WITH
STAYING IN SCOPE FOR NOT
VENTURING OUT INTO THE THINGS
THAT THE PRIVATE MANUFACTURERS
ARE BRINGING TO THE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE COMING IN ON
REGULATED SO PROCESSES LIKE
MICRO BLADING WHICH ARE NOT
PART OF OUR SCOPE OF PRACTICE
IN CALIFORNIA ARE BEING BROUGHT
INTO THE PRIVATIZED SCHOOLS ALL
THE TIME. SO THOSE STUDENTS ARE
LEARNING THESE PROCESSES THAT
ARE WAY OUT OF SCOPE OF
PRACTICE IN THESE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS WITH WITH NO NO I HAVE
REPERCUSSIONS SO THEY GO OUT
INTO THE INDUSTRY ON THEIR OWN
USUALLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
AN EMPLOYMENT SITUATION TO GO
TO THEY JUST OPEN UP SHOP START
A BUSINESS LICENSE AND THEY'RE
ON THEIR OWN. SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PEOPLE THAT ARE THEY'RE
NOT REALLY BEING SUPERVISED
VERY HONESTLY THEY ARE COMING
OUT AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
WORK IN AN ACTUAL SALON
ENVIRONMENT AS AN EMPLOYEE.
THEY'RE ALL FREELANCERS DOING
THEIR OWN THING. SO THESE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE EVERYONE TO
CONSIDER WHEN YOU'RE MAKING
YOUR DECISIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE WISH
TO TESTIFY. SO YOU'RE GONNA BE
ENTERTAINED FOR TWENTY MORE
SECONDS THIS REAL QUICK BECAUSE
ROCK THANK YOU. I DID THE BASIC
MATH HERE FOR THE OREGON
STACKABLE LICENSING. AND
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES THE
COSMETOLOGY AESTHETICS AND
NAILS AND IF YOU ADD THOSE
TOGETHER THAT'S NINETEEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN HOURS. AND
CUT IT EVERY OTHER STATES ABOUT
THE SAME WAY. AND WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE A COSMETOLOGY
LICENSING ONLY THAT CARRIES ALL
THOSE. CATEGORIES WITH SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS SO IT IS A
STREAMLINED. LICENSING TO
PROVIDE ALL THOSE THOSE.
DISCIPLINES AND ALSO REMEMBER
THAT WE OF APPROVED ELEVEN
HUNDRED OUR HAIR STYLING
LICENSE TO WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THEM VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR A
CLOSING COMMENT SOMEONE INVITE
DATE COULD. MY CO CHAIR LOW TO
A SHARE HIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR AGAIN WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THOSE WHO HAVE COME OUT
TODAY TO PROVIDE. OTHER INPUT
CERTAINLY THERE ARE NUMBER OF
ISSUE SAID TO BE ADDRESSED BY
THINK THIS HELPS. I PROVIDED
SOME DIRECTION ON THE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES IN
COMPARISON TO THE OTHER STATES.
CERTAINLY I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
JUST STATE THAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GIVEN OUR CAPACITY
THAT WE DO LIKE TO. SET THE
STANDARDS IN THE LEAD WITH
RESPECT TO THE NATION JUST
GIVEN THE SCOPE AND THE TYPE
OF. DEMOGRAPHICS AND ECONOMIC
ENGINE THAT WE ARE AS A STATE.
I ALSO WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT
THAT I KNOW THAT THERE. COULD
BE SME ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION
WITHOUT OF THE BOARD OF
CURRENTLY AS I UNDERSTAND IT WE
ONLY  CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE OF
THE NINE. BOARD MEMBERS THAT
HAVE BEEN FILLED SO THEY'RE
CURRENTLY A NUMBER OF VACANCIES
WITH RESPECT TO THE BOARD SO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS. THAT TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
AND GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE THAT
CAN BE APPLICABLE AND SO WE
NEED TO ASK THAT QUESTION AS TO
WHY THEY WERE. ON THOSE
OUTSTANDING VACANCIES A
SIMILARLY WILL MENTION AND
MIGHT BE A BROKEN RECORD AS WE
CONTINUE ONE OF THESE ON PUBLIC
HEARINGS BUT I DO THINK THAT
THAT JUST GIVEN THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AS WELL. OF THAT
OF THE LICENSE POPULATION OF
THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
SHOULD BE REFLECTED. AND HAVE
THAT INPUT AS WELL SO NO THAT
WILL ELICIT THAT ENGAGEMENT.
AND THEN. FINALLY MAY ALSO JUST
MENTION THAT I KNOW THAT AS A
POINT OF. INFORMATION THAT THIS
THE SECOND INFORMATIONAL
HEARING UP FOR THIS. BOARD AND
I KNOW THAT WE WILL BE
EXPLORING AN ADDITIONAL ADD
ADDITIONAL INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. BEFORE THE LEGISLATIVE
SESSION AND THEN RE CONVENES IN
ADDITION TO THE VARIOUS POLICY
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS THAT WE
WILL HAVE BOTH IN TE ASSEMBLY
AND IN THE SENATE. AS WELL AS
THE APPROPRIATIONS IN THE
FISCAL COMPONENTS SO FOR
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD NOT BE THE
BORDER OR DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE
CONVERSATION WITH RESPECT TO
THE MINISTRATIONS HAVING
RESERVATION ON POLICY CHANGES
WITHOUT FRAUD STAKEHOLDER INPUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIS PROSTATE
COLDER INPUT AND SO THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT THE
SERBS SUBSTANTIVE POLICY.
CHANGES SHOULD BE MADE IN THESE
SUNSET BILLS OR IF THIS IS
APPROPRIATE VEHICLE AGAIN THERE
ARE THREE IN BUT THREE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS IN
ADDITION TO THE POLICY HERE IS
THAT WE HAVE SO AS TO REFLECTED
HERE WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
POLICY CONVERSATIONS AND FRAUD
INFORMATIONAL INPUT SO AGAIN OF
THE OF THE CONVERSATION WITH
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD BE SUCH
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE. TO
ELICIT AS MUCH BROAD
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AS POSSIBLE
SO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
CHAIR AND TO THE STAFF WE'VE
ALSO ENGAGED IN A CONVERSATION
THANK YOU TEACHER LOW AND THANK
YOU TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF YOUR
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS IN MANY
AREAS IN OUR LICENSING WORLD
CERTAINLY THANK YOU TO OUR TO
OUR STAFF HERE IN THE SENATE.
TO THOSE WHO HAVE COME TO
TESTIFY TODAY THANK YOU AND
MEMBERS THE. WHO HAVE SPECIAL
EXPERTISE WHICH I APPRECIATE.
FOR SURE IN THEIR THOUGHTS
THANK YOU AS WELL. AND I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT A CONSTRUCTIVE
SUGGESTIONS THAT HAVE COME EVEN
TODAY FROM THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. THAT'S THE IMPORTANT
PART OF THE WORK THAT WE DO IS
THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN YOUR
IDEAS. WE WANT TO DO THINGS
BETTER THAT'S THE WHOLE GOAL
HERE IS THAT WE WANT TO BE
SMARTER. AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE PUBLIC. IS PROTECTED.
AND SO I APPRECIATE IN
PARTICULAR THE IDEAS THAT YOU
HAVE COME OUT TODAY. ABOUT HOW
WE MIGHT EXAMINE THE AT THE
THESE THESE ISSUES AS WE GO
FORWARD. ABOUT WITH
CONSTRUCTIVE IDEAS AND WHAT WE
WANT TO AVOID AND I. I I'M SURE
THAT MY AYE COCHAIR FEELS THE
SAME. IS THAT WE DON'T WANT TO.
MAKE LAST MINUTE CHANGES IN THE
SUMMER. TO THESE PROGRAMS WE
WANT TO HAVE THESE IDEAS WE
PRIDE OUT AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
SO TO HAVE CONSTRUCTIVE
ENGAGEMENT MEANS THE TO GET IN
THE GAME AND TO COME UP WITH
YOUR THOUGHTS AND IDEAS AND
THAT CERTAINLY APPLIES. TO
FOLKS THAT HAVE COME TODAY AND
IT CERTAINLY APPLIES TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. I WANTED TO
MENTIONED INCLUDING INCLUSION
THAT. WE ARE GOING TO BE
MEETING IN THE COMING MONTHS TO
LEARN ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE OF
STUDENTS. WHO ATTENDED BOARD
APPROVED. SCHOOL EXPERIENCES WE
WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
PERSPECTIVE ABOARD LICENSEES AS
WE HAVE HEARD. AND WE WANT TO
TALK TO A- WE WANNA LOOK AT THE
REALITIES OF CONSUMERS WHO ARE
SEEKING OUT AND RECEIVING
BEAUTIFICATION SERVICES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND HOW
THAT'S WORKING. LICENSE AND ON
LICENSE AND WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING ABOUT IT. AND SO WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
MY COACH HERE. HELLO AND THANK
YOU FOR TUNING IN OR
PARTICIPATING AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS. I IN THE MONTHS
AHEAD. AND WITH THAT THIS
MEETING. IS ADJOURNED